and we may be getting a few extra
in-game lessons ourselves today courtesy
of magnus carlsen and Wesley so thank
you to master class and the one and only
Gary Kasparov for that little intro we
are two minutes past the hour and the
game is beginning right about now we see
Magnus and in a jovial mood he's ready
to play whoever he's talking to there in
the room with him Eric Grand Master Eric
Hanson the one the only mr. chess
brought the fearless leader of the chest
broad world thank you for flying
alongside me here buddy are you ready
I'm ready Dani I try to you know escape
from you every month but it seems like
I'm pulled back in but I'm happy to be
here we're not letting you go anywhere
and right now we've got the match of of
the month with Magnus Carlsen taking on
the American Grandmaster Wesley so and a
very very highly anticipated matchup
here very very big big odds in Magnus
Carlson's favor if you believe chess
coms segment time controlled breakdowns
based on how these players have perform
Eric you saw us feature this new
algorithm is system we've been working
on in the last show as a spectator so as
you look at our predictions here and
they scheme kicks off what do you think
about it I do tend to agree with how
they're predicting it Danny I think I
think most people after I mean going
into the event Magnus Carlsen right now
is he's boasting the highest us rating
ever in in after his recent performance
in st. Louis this past week and I've
seen him playing on chess calm recently
as well so I think he's just trying to
win every single format possible but he
actually he's actually managing here
well you didn't just have the the
courtesy of seeing him playing chess Tom
recently you and him kind of stopped the
the online chess world in a battle
royale how was that throwing down with
Magnus as he as he seemed to get better
as that match went on against you that
that's a good way to assess it it was
the most fun I've had ever playing
playing on blitz match but it was also
the toughest I never I've never been
broken so badly in the final
we're just like the goods you know he
gets better as the match goes on and
it's extremely hard to keep keep up with
with him he just doesn't make mistakes
at a certain point and we all make
mistakes when they have one one minute
on the clock one thing one thing about
Magnus Danny is his time management is
just unbelievable yeah like he just
never puts himself in a vulnerable
situation like even in uncomfortable
positions he's just really good at
handling the clock and it's and it's it
was it was sort of when I rewatched the
match I was like I didn't miss many
times where I could actually add one
well we are gonna keep a close eye on
what our match predictor says everybody
you can see that bar starting out at a
predicted outcome that seems kind of
crazy at first that anybody would be
favored 95% to win almost anything which
puts it about almost 20 to 1 odds but
the truth is when you actually evaluate
what the format of these matches are
that there's a lot of games that are
gonna be played we predicted 30 games
between these two players based that's
one of the things that our algorithm
predicts is based on how fast they each
player wins and loses and what can
happen with that so right now it starts
out we'll keep we'll keep an eye out on
what our predictions are as the match
goes on and of course keeping an eye on
on the players and and the actual chess
moves themselves but will we'll keep an
eye on this everybody and stay tuned to
see just how much just how much effort
we put into trying to predict these
things and whether we end up being right
but all right let's talk about this this
game here Eric we also have a new bell
bells and whistles we're featuring here
today with the sliding evaluation bar on
the left side of the board letting
people know what stockfish thinks of the
position as it goes we're not going to
worry too much what stockfish thinks
because we're here to educate and
entertain but for those who are really
curious and sometimes it's exciting when
you see that bar go crazy because
somebody blundered you can keep an eye
on that evaluation bar to the left of it
we had a Queen's Indian that turned into
a hedgehog that turned into black having
the bishop pair Eric and and now a very
very strong past b-pawn I'm already
liking Magnus's chances here in Game one
no I mean you don't see people really
come from behind to be Magnus I think
Wesley has to have you know a perfect
match and a great start this is not the
start this is blackest as just you could
describe it in many ways but he's got
the two bishops who protected past pawn
just a much better position Danny with
with blacken and that's that's not
obviously really wants the VIII cc4
being a big weakness in the long run and
you just have no way to challenge these
bishops so it's going to be a long-term
squeeze and Wesley is going to have to I
don't know be very tenacious this game
this is this is this is looking actually
terrible to me just because in the long
run you don't want to open the position
against individuals but the same time
it's very hard practically speaking to
just sit back and let Magnus improve
this position yeah I mean it's it's kind
of the recipe to lose to Magnus
regardless of the time control and we
can see that after this move f4
according to according to the engine is
also the engine agrees with Grandmaster
Eric Hanson as black is breaking through
on the e-file Queen before coming and
after king of - I think Bishop takes c4
should win the game something like 24
followed by Bishop c4 and no way to play
92 I guess black can just gobble up the
night and then go for that same idea
yeah and I guess his ideas after King F
- Bishop c4 he's actually threatening
mate with Queen takes c3 king of yeah
Queen takes c3 and no this is this is
just over this is just like a wipe out
and round and round one Wesley
really impressed a lot of people in the
chess world one of the most impressive
comebacks I've ever seen against
Dominguez this past week yeah it was but
Magnus is just a much different animal
there and I don't think he can that's
good news because that's showing a
different side of us they were you know
sometimes you know he can get down on
himself and yeah pretty but he came back
and won and I was that was that means in
this match you know we always have that
factor but a really really one-sided win
for Magnus something went wrong in the
opening there for those who don't know
the the match that Eric Hanson is
talking about these Chess Club and
scholastic Center in st. Louis held some
really epic matches in this last week
one where Magnus Carlsen obliterated his
opponent Dingley Wren but Wesley so
falling behind left a lot on the table
literally his blood in one game if
you want to Google Wesley so bleeds on
o'clock I bet you'll find are on my
clients picture from on site there so
Wesley yeah he did perform well and I
agree with you I think one of the things
about Wesley people have said is when
it's going really well
it goes well but but does he have that
mental toughness to carry him through
some of those you know some of those
moments where you have to persevere and
I think he did that this last week
versus Dominguez and and he may need to
do that today I want to give a shout out
that we've already had three people's
three new subscribers to our channel
freo dr. Jerry and then the initial one
I'm sorry I missed your username cuz
Eric was saying something awesome and I
was just i black out when Erich is
saying awesome stuff Eric so what do we
have what awesome stuff you have to say
about this one an interesting pawn
structure here where white is facing
toward the Kings side with a big chain
black is gonna organize the c5 move this
is one of those carro cons where you
have a French pawn structure but the
bishop is outside of the normal that
normally it's a bad piece kind of locked
in behind these pawns maybe give give
the fans some thoughts about what both
sides are playing here like why do you
want to mention one thing was they said
this past week is he's probably gonna
play the Berlin lesson blitz it didn't
go so well so that's why we're seeing
him play the character cannon instead of
some of his more solid options
interesting didn't didn't works too well
but then when he switched to the sharper
options worked well in this position
White's moves it's all about positional
control just maintaining the structure
of this punch in from b2 to e5 that's
going to enable white to have a lot of
space to play behind those pawns you're
gonna see options like at some point you
might want to put you know play f4 f5
under the right circumstances here this
is a simpler approach Magnus who's gonna
put a piece on d4 it's gonna be a pretty
quiet game some Carroll cannons go
pretty crazy different ways of handling
it but I think it's gonna be about white
getting the f2 pod to support the e5
pawn at some point and then maybe
pushing even further down the board
because otherwise black sort of some
people like to call these positions like
a good French that he's trade-off flat
squared bishop and he has counter play
against White's Center so it's a
balanced game right now but this last
move Queen d4 invites the shot
Knight f5 that maybe wins the bishop on
e3 so if the Queen's come off the board
right now or even if this night is
traded by the bishop who does that favor
I think of favors block because
the open sea file and pressure against
e5e5e5 on the on the board and in this
position Magnus I think you made the
right choice to keep the goons on the
board but I don't think I don't think
black has any issues here at all it
seems like you spied very logical chess
and this last movie six is pretty nice
as well threatening Bishop h6 and
potentially more problems for the Queen
starting to like Wesley's chances in
this in this second game here always got
his pawns on the right color that's one
thing you can notice and in terms of
evaluating some these positions yep the
end games blacks gonna have the pressure
against the Darkspear pawns what I get
you know maintenance that's how this
knight on d4 I I think was he's been
doing great here yeah part of the reason
Erik said that everybody that the saying
Black has his pawns on the right color
he means they're on the opposite color
square of the bishop which typically
gives your Bishop even more open lines
and even more mobility so sometimes
grandmasters make comments like that
because they're they're so strong and
international masters lowly
international masters like myself have
to translate it for the rest of world
Erik but anyway yeah good stuff and as
you predicted that ePHI pawn Falls it
was on the color of the dark square
bishop so Wesley was able to corral it
and now as we head into the endgame
though with everything with all the
smoke clearing I have a hard time
believing Wesley can win this as black
despite that good opening a middle game
just because his King is so open know
that exchange didn't really benefit him
he doesn't work with here and the
problem is a six is weak g6 is a week so
he's offering to trade everything off
but well one thing if the rooks get
trade off daddy how do you evaluate
cleaning games past pawns and actually
whites blacks epon is the probably
quickest one to to the touchdown zone so
that's what do i mains kept the rooks on
the board you can harass the King a bit
but he didn't have out he didn't like
his chances my queen game just because
the the prospect of the week back rating
for white and blacks
pasty pawn which can be ushered in
pretty quickly with E 5 before e3 scared
him off so Wesley's still doing well
here he's still the one pushing this
engine name it's a nice light upon and
also a passed pawn and
White's week PACCAR Inc means he can
really focus on it
okay well now that the g2 pawn is a
target the problem for black is can you
really gang up on on things on the
second-ranked without your own king
right that's the issue the more pieces
are the more the harder is to anticipate
those checks in that kind of clay and
that's why I think rook she won by me
this was quite a smart practical
decision it looks very positive a lot of
people would just discount it but
keeping the Queens on the board keeping
the works on the word adds an element
where if black makes a mistake you might
people find themself getting made it
right well the position now does Magnus
have a chance at some point if this g2
pawn isn't under target to swing to see
one that's why you're saying that maybe
black doesn't get made it if he's not
careful that's right you you make some
play h3 give the King some space and if
he's in go pawn grabbing I guess Magnus
wants the a pawn and now he's gonna
start pushing it okay 3d five by the way
is a great square to put the Queen Nana
does everything protects c6 history too
and it's an outpost as well so you're
not gonna go under it so we have a bit
of a race now where were Magnus's
slightly on the worse side of it I guess
just because the e pawn can be pushed
the a pawn can't with black holding the
a5 square twice but now if if Wesley
takes a four are we gonna see moves like
rook c1 or rook beep yeah
that's precisely why you know the the O
king of King Ichi does not look right
just something's off I mean maybe
doesn't lose but I can hardly believe
blacks is making progress
you have 25 right it hits g6 and
protects g2 so suddenly this rook has
been freed everybody freedom the rook
will run to one of these open files and
maybe get involved in the attack oh this
is this is getting very dangerous
because now if I move like King g7 you
got options like Rick c1 you're
defending the maid so you have time to
counter-attack rooks you wanna rock f1
or rook over p1 g7 is not the idea so
Brooke c1 and rook f1 or Ricky one those
are the three rook moves I see here all
all being useful he wants to play for a
win you should just go for mate here if
you want to liquidate rook e1 should
pick up the e5 pawn
yeah if the e5 pawn Falls for the a for
pawn I mean even their white could still
have mating chances probably though
trade will occur and and black will be
fine but yeah rook f1 I think says
Magnus wants to play for more than just
a trade here here I he was he
threatening Queen f6 I guess he was so
what's that you're threatened yeah yeah
Queen e7 as well I had to give the rook
also room to maneuver on the on that
thought and this is where Magnus Carlsen
is so tough right certainly he didn't
get the best opening we like Wesley Soze
caro-kann there but after having an edge
in the middle game it doesn't look like
Wesley was able to fully capitalize and
now if anything it feels like Magnus is
about to be the one on the hunt for sure
the one good thing for Wesley is Queen
on g6 if not only protects b8 but
there's a threat of rookie one check
King edge - there's a discovered efore
move at his disposal so the Queen on d6
is really good at protecting g6 and
covering a few key squares but yeah this
looks super dangerous I don't I'm trying
to find a win here for white because
black is very quick to come up with rook
rook a1 and yeah that move of threatens
Queen c8 mate but also protects a1 this
is this feels like white should have
something but he's gonna have to spend
some of his two and a half minutes that
to find that out the players are playing
pretty quickly this game for for the G
you me cash for subscribing thank you
for supporting chests and being here to
watch the speech Chess Championship okay
its Queen f7 an issue if ok then we'll
go back to book a one right and then he
bore end up getting mitad yeah so we
could see a little bit of tickle here
back and forth between the Queen and
King and this is Magnus he would like
yeah as much as Magnus would like to
play something like this everybody just
highlight Eric Hanson's line one more
time black would get a four check and
the the tables would turn with white
finding himself mated so so mag is
taking a little bit of a think here
maybe assessing if that's really the
case or if he has any other chances he
as he looks away maybe somebody's
cooking up something good in the kitchen
but likely Magnus is just going to
repeat here
okay interesting stuff well to start out
back to our our game timer remind
everybody we are only 15 minutes in here
Game one went quickly to the reigning
world champion as he won with the black
pieces and in an opening that went
terribly wrong for Wesley so but but
here Wesley's played better for sure I
mean he's definitely stopped the
bleeding getting an edge as black to
start a small edge at that and and with
Magnus I think having to settle on a
draw here you just got to be happy
you're not starting with two losses
right now as Wesley and you go back with
the white pieces oh look at that I'm
wrong he's playing for a win he plays
Queen f8 to guard the 86 square one of
the problems there was Magnus done so
much time Wesley was able to find an
improvement on his original like you
know I idea of maybe selling for a draw
gonna have a cumbers age six also my
prepared to play the move Queen f4 which
would put the pressure on white cover
covers White's escape skirt so yeah I
agree with this decision here downy he's
helped upon and and Agnes is usually on
the other side of this Rickey one check
or here Queen f4 and at least box is
playing up upon after like f7 I don't
see yeah it's still still very likely a
jaw everybody this rook ending despite
black having this extra pawn with them
with the King being cut off on the
eighth rank by the white rook expect
this to end to a draw but I agree and
you like the tenacity there from Wesley
right Magnus Wilson thinks he has a draw
and he says not so fast I'm gonna push
this one for a little while I mean he's
gonna have to maximize every every extra
pawn yesterday you know hope for Mouse
lips hope for blunders but try to try to
try to have Magnus on the other other
end of the grinds h4 is a nice move
right in a small instructional point for
our members at home just that it holds
the g5 square and prevents Wesley from
doing what he might want to do want to
move like King F to g5 and you know it's
it's probably a draw either way but just
a little instructional point for members
on the analysis board here that you
don't want your opponent to have all
their pawns together and healthy so
Magnus sort of aggressively trying to
hold back the black pawns and I think
that's gonna make the draw even easier
for white yeah here we go the trade will
happen is right in time King age six
rook to accept to his king will be in
time to offended otherwise yeah could be
some issues but Weston's playing the
song
he's it's gonna be the draw he's gonna
speak to that a little bit cuz we know
you you have such a unique perspective
from any of the hosts here because
you're one of the strongest online and
online blitz players and and bullet
players and so you played both these
guys and what what is it about is there
is there something to the practical
aspect Eric of working out your nerves
right trying to trying to put yourself
in a position where even though Wesley
of course knows this is a draw and he's
not gonna beat Magnus here is is he
playing it out just so that he can kind
of work out some of those initial match
jitters do you ever do that in a match
like this yeah I think it makes a lot of
sense in this case because he had such a
bad first game that he you know he wants
to extend the game's practice playing
some consistent chess which is what he's
known for he really doesn't that first
game was a bit uncharacteristic that was
a real bla and I think that mainly
happens when Wesley plays Magnus right
so I think it's gonna be a confidence
builder to see himself up upon to see
himself in end games where he's playing
a to result a game where you can win or
draw I think that that's gonna build
some confidence and I think that's
pretty big for Wesley me spending a guy
like Magnus he has you know he's never
beaten in some formats and just has as a
native spar against right well playing
fast here to start this next game we see
Wesley with 5 minutes and 6 seconds
everybody more time than then he started
with but and so as a match goes on you
think that that's part of partly why you
might play on games like that just the
fact that you psychologically get used
to looking at a board where you have an
advantage against Magnus Carlsen right
the world champion and that's something
Wesley's gonna need in his favor as the
as the gloves come off here today oh for
sure would have been useful for me I
stopped getting good positions at a
certain point and Magnus he really
starts finding his rhythm and so you got
to try to stop him there
Tyrel get those good you know good end
games I agree with the choice I
understand why he's doing it alright
well now we have this knight on e5 and
probably a little bit of an edge for
white here this is sort of a typical
kind of whatever this was a Larsson
Larsson 93 b3 we saw Hikaru Nakamura use
this opening a lot against Fabiano
Caruana and their match is there
something to this opening here that it
may be maybe just a kind of comfortable
blitz opening where the plans are easy
for white
coordinate the nights the moves are able
you know you're developing very fast is
that is that one of the reasons you see
this opening and blitz so often yes easy
to make moves easy to pre move and it
doesn't matter too much what your
opponent does so you really can come up
with a pretty quick start one thing I'll
say is it's also just a fun opening for
black as well
okay keys hanging upon positions you can
play a bit aggressively and it's a lot
harder for whites maybe find the precise
position moves that often you know
stifled these openings so I think I
think it's good for both sides Magnus is
gonna have to play dynamic to justify I
mean he's expanded a bit those pawns are
also targets so sort of we'll see who
imposes there well here but hasn't been
talked about this move f6 right a little
bit I mean so it obviously has the clear
intention of removing the knight from
such a strong square but also a move
that could eventually have some-some
backfire capabilities with the lights
we're what it was going on here oh yeah
it was just after he took first he went
create that isolated pawn but yeah I
wisely had this c6 in-between move that
Magnus may have missed yeah
not entirely sure but what I see now is
just white should be positionally better
and what I mean the trade of the the
whites deep on for black sea pawn is a
big big big plus for white because ya
know white can isolate this d5 pawn
highlighting that line with c6 showing
everybody what Wesley calculated that he
would have his choice of winning the a6
or the e4 Knight with Queen 65 and so
there's a very good point Erik so now
with that transition that maybe Magnus
missed when he played f6 we have this
position on the board where black is
clearly the one positionally worse with
the d5 pawn being isolated ya know he's
lost a lot of the dynamic possible
possibility like it in the structure but
black box only good piece here I mean
not I shouldn't say that for the 94 you
don't want to do something with that you
want to coordinate that but the problem
is Magnus is gonna have to sit and think
pretty soon here to figure out how he
can avoid this momentum or black where
white just turn trade everything off but
this is a very nice idea here by Magnus
he's actually forcing the trade on c5
not very often is a knight involved in a
fork but here the knight is it is just
oh what happened here all losing some
material here I mean Queen a3 may work
but it looks like a move you don't want
to play you might get embarrassed on you
know like night one night to d3
everybody to do three and then there's
before and you're you're holding on but
you're not entirely sure so but here
he's just down exchange and what lost
although this allows ninety sixty seven
and officially through there's twenty
five okay so Bishop III Queenie five or
or communicate okay that also saves the
exchange huh Queenie five but this is
better though no this goes into the end
game with his productive path on the
other line
yeah Queenie five might have might have
been better but this is also really
comfortable end game just because he's
got that protected passport right I
think I didn't promise Brooke p8 here is
maybe Brooke d1 is a little too quick so
I think white can when the B file first
Leon Magnus if he put 25 might may have
just been winning on the spot that's
super interesting there I mean it felt
like f6 is played and Wesley finds this
nice little trick to create nicely to
clean pawn but then immediately over
plays his hand on the Queen side Eric
and gets his own Queen trap that's
that's that's got to be disappointing
there yeah yeah no I think he was quite
comfortable his position and just
completely missed that idea this game
has you know we're seeing the players
still get into the the rhythm there's
been a few inaccuracies that's obviously
going to happen like here for his part
yeah he's maximizing the king I'm not
sure but another quick p7 yeah Ricky
said I'm not sure how he's planning to
deal with it but his his ideas he
doesn't mind giving up on Danny
he needs his work on b2 yeah he'd love
for white to take on 87 and play would
be to and use that active King active C
pawn and rook to generate a lot of kind
of play on well in what's wings head
yeah
showing that line for the fans they're
saying it's an instructional moment to
remind them that active rooks are often
worth upon in the end games right the
div arrests
Siri you'd rather have the more active
King in the more active rook then than a
pawn and Wesley knows that too though
which is why he didn't just go take
eight
seven and allow that rook b8 idea and
now now he may be able to win the C pawn
with rook c7 check and take c4 even
though that allows him move like rookie
- so sort of a a lot to think about here
which is why Wesley's taking a moment
yeah we're kinda means these are these
are very tough to evaluate you can win
the C pawn he allows Ricky to I don't
think you want a lot of rookie to that's
all that's all I think a draw if you can
get a draw is good well you know Kings
love it when they get involved in a game
of tickle there and easy to pass the
time black again holds a draw so magnets
not really that upset even though he was
the one pushing for a win
let's add a laugh they're not sure
what's going on there Magnus in a pretty
like we said a pretty happy mood today
wherever he is there want to give a
shout out as the next game gets underway
here to the chat chess bay and all the
regulars hanging out in the twitch TV
slash chess chat and then all of our
members at chests calm slash TV we see
you guys yep in a way thanks for being
here thanks for watching and thanks for
subscribing and supporting our show yeah
we are following the chat every we're
seeing a lot of something like seeing a
lot of activity there which is good as
the atmosphere when people are chatting
cheering trolling chatting cheering
trolling and those are the the three CH
of the twitch chat that's just chatting
cheering troubling all right what do we
have here this is a kind of an awkward
little caro-kann you made it a point
already to say Wesley is going to avoid
playing the Berlin Blitz today but but
this caro-kann is not one you see every
day with black having an isolated pawn
but also up upon as it currently stands
in the center yeah what seems like me if
for example white were two queens at
Casa that box a little bit quicker to
the punch maybe not the structure is
worse but in terms of how to play this
so you know you get to play nicely six
bishop if I have a pretty simple
position for black I guess what that
means Danny is Wesley wants to keep
pieces on the board because white will
win back that deed for pawn in
maintenance is evaluating do I do it now
or later and and post a better structure
right so this is this is going to be a
sharp game because it's not in blacks
interest
especially with that last minute by
magnets castling long right I mean you
put the Kings on opposite sides of the
board here everybody look for Wesley so
to try to use the B file and attack and
for Magnus to try to rush the Jeep on
even if it means losing the Jeep on I
think here here maybe you'll play Bishop
d3 and not be too worried about black
taking on f3 because it would open the G
file or what do you expect that would be
that impossible and he's done it there
weren't too many options black block is
super active here Magnus with this move
yes he's inviting complications right
because all of a sudden his structure
would be pretty bad too I think black is
doing quite ok here though Danny you
definitely gonna have three he just
developed yeah I very comfortably and
somehow yeah I mean if that was ok a3
happens I mean Larkin the reason why you
said that Eric was about to say that
move has to be played Queen takes b6 you
know black is doing okay because no
Grandmaster wants to trade and help fix
his opponent's pawn structure right no
yes Magnus will take one weakness and
win a game with it yep okay well Wesley
still maintains a little bit of an edge
here but maybe lack of understanding I
would have strongly considered Bishop
takes f3 moves like at age five and post
an ad on f4 that seems like a very
dangerous variation I'm not sure it's a
lack of understanding maybe a missed
opportunity by Wesley B got it twice yet
it twice and Magnus allowed I'm just
appalled Magnus had to it was pin but
right that was available two times now
there's 94 94 needs to be considered
anyways a very very good position for
Wesley without any your end and a lot of
his losses in his Magnus I've looked in
the past he has actually lost in
complicated position that he sort of had
some had some poor games in in solid in
sort of symmetrical positions he doesn't
you know that's not where he's going
straight against Magnus interesting
tactical shout there by Magnus 94
everybody you've got f2 hanging you've
got g4 hanging and Wesley finds what I
think was the best move just to say you
know what I don't need any of that I'll
back up the bishop and guard c6 and I
maintain an edge because because why cuz
this efile here everybody black has the
a file Wesley remains in a comfortable
position here though you got to say that
with the knight on d4
I guess it's better than it was a little
earlier and this part on f3 oh it's in
people's position whites let's
definitely improve his position it's
[ __ ] comfortable for black we're
singing g5 y g5 well just again space
allows the King maybe g7 have six and
ice around outside also he's thinking
about end games what he might want
responds on dark Spurs and strengthen
his life's great bishop so before is a
good move as well because black wanted
to play B 4 and C 5 and get a sorry c5
and d4 black wanted you know that be
nice on structure be 65 d4 not a
compliment this light squared bishop
real well so right now he's bringing the
King in slightly better and game for for
Wesley but I think this is the type of
the game I think the fans are hoping to
see like it's gonna go along Wesley in
this case is the one pushing and he's
gonna have to make the most of these
positions today it's a bishop c8
everybody Wesley was trying to get a
move like Bishop a6 where he could trade
off White's LightSquared Bishop because
that would open up the c-4 square for
the knight so nice idea but Magnus
Magnus can dove puts the stop to among
d5 no b5 all of a sudden you're you're
beautiful pawn structure gets gets
ruined and I think we all we all we all
cry a little inside isolated pawns know
now that position is completely good
fine for black eye for white I should
say Magnus is not in any trouble and you
might be looking to play blues like Age
4 soon Danny and there it is
h4 everybody hoping that Wesley might
take it rook h1 suddenly white gets 2
targets for the price of one pawn so
Wesley not interested in doing that
alright I'm I have to say the position
I'm sitting now I don't like as much as
the finest argued the tables are turning
here slowly but surely even nice e6 and
then Knight d4 is an interesting plan
for white just to kind of relocate the
pony and poke at the d5 pawn it c6
yeah yeah blacks gonna have to move his
King away from that I stay upon through
some day b8 funny checks going on there
the Magnus is making progress I mean
this position has been getting better
and better even though it's come should
be objectively very close to equal that
rook is trapped whoa you've got it we've
almost had two games
see Wesley so kind of look over his left
shoulder and shake his head like I gots
to be played and that is not to move now
there's 96 a night before your idea is
very strong here yeah but this this is
putting all your pawns unlucky like b 5d
vials are just targets for whites
LightSquared bishop and well positioned
rook on d1 Magnus has turned the tables
here and he's pushing
yeah just super well played there that
that transition into the endgame Magnus
a cards I'm deciding whether he wants to
take on b5 here I think or play nice e6
check because you can just take on b5
again no and well how do you take on b5
because if Bishop b5 I take back with my
bishop and if you take my bishop I take
back with my knight I have in 90s yeah
oh and you got a rook e1 discovered
check yeah in term is aware you have
rook e1 and then you gobble up the rook
on a four so so Magnus is okay and he
goes for it you he he goes for a size XP
5 they trade everything off he's got
this rook e1 check because otherwise you
run in tonight takes three destructive
lying there to show the fans Magnus
can't just take here because he would
lose material in the end but he's
calculated the intermezzo appropriately
and he will gobble the Brooke and B I
mean this is a problem down him because
his rook rook a5 that might just be like
97 or something yeah Mesmer weight is
okay five you know before is almost
interesting I guess you know I guess you
wouldn't do it cuz he would probably
give up the brook happily here to pieces
but but you're right it's it's a tough
spot for Wesley there and and you know
we saw him kind of shake his head there
everybody when he got his second rook
awkwardly trapped or I guess you could
say the Queen was awkwardly trapped in a
previous game and here the rook so it'll
be interesting to see how Wesley handles
this transition as he looks for his best
chances to draw and there that's what he
decides keeping the knight on the board
rook takes here Rick h2 bishop f1 I mean
the big problem is the a pawn is just
faster than everybody by far
yeah white might just start pushing a
four right away and here it goes oh this
should be lost I mean yeah you know
there's an argument to be made right now
though that Magnus Carlsen is coming
into this
master in his best speech as form ever
he's defending champion he's at his
all-time high feed a rating and he just
demolished I mean ding Lear and that is
that is a pretty remarkable result
statistically to like yep what was that
he would have been over three thousand
if if it counted games after he won but
like I think I think this is uh not
interested in letting myself be tortured
in this one and you know again you make
a good point we bring up what the
pre-match prediction stats were here
everybody according to our our metrics
that we are working on more and more so
we can have really cool ways to predict
chess matches of all kinds not just on
chess calm but Carlsen pre predicted to
win this match by nineteen and a half to
ten and a half right now on pace to to
stay right there with it and like you
said it much as much as those seem
extreme like extreme odds magnus carlsen
coming off the st. Louis for those who
didn't follow that matt is it is playing
playing chess like nobody else in the
world right now
yeah looking back at his matches he even
played in this format he hasn't lost any
blitz portions yet and I think he lost
uh narrowly to Hikaru in their match in
the bullet part but in blitz I mean he
is being just so consistent so so so
consistent I mean it's always he builds
up a lead and maybe he allows too much
counter play and he tells us in the
postgame into do I I gave too much kind
of but he's all this position officer
he's just always starting off well yeah
and he's one of the last guys on earth
you'd expect to blow lead so Wesley
should already have a sense of urgency
main is just not controlling the pace of
the match which is one of the reasons I
brought up the opening approach there
from Wesley he goes back to this sort of
NIM so Larson ready type of whatever I
don't even know the name of it but
Knight of three and b3 and you know at
some point you wonder if he may have to
go to some more mainline stuff that he
would have prepared for for over the
board tournaments and try to test Magnus
and in sharp waters because I agree with
you I think you got to get wins early if
you're Wesley and not let this match get
out of control we have a question from
the chat about whether Magnus knows he's
on camera Magnus knows he's on camera
he just that that's that's Magnus on
camera there you go
they both know they're on camera and
what's going on here a weird Wesley
shook his head but this is a weird
position I don't think Magnus is gonna
be able to hold on to that d4 pawn is
isn't white just a little better here if
this deep worse there are some tactics
it's yes why does better view wins the
pawn but there are some there are some
tactics here against f2 and I'm not sure
the best way to handle that because if
you do Bishop takes d4 uh-huh you win
the pawn maybe not in the long run
actually no it just loses Bishop b4 94th
there should be some some sort of pin
with an oxford bishop yep so he can't
win the pawn comfortably and wall blocks
next moves down you're gonna be like
Bishop a5 rook 88 and rook f e8 just
showing the fans the line you were
talking about on the analysis board
where why Wesley can't just go straight
forward and gobble that D pawn and so he
settles I like this line because of 93
you can take with your bishop what you
don't want to do but you have a quick
follow up of 94 maybe maybe that solves
your issues you have to take maybe what
he has to do now right Magnus sort of
forces his hand and says alright I may
lose the pawn but I get rid of your dark
square Bishop and that's important
everybody because as the board opens up
if this Bishop on g7 doesn't have a
challenger you got to be careful of
tactics on this diagonal so here comes
Queen e7 I anticipate yeah and the
reason is that Magnus can go get the c5
pawn but Wesley goes right for the ooh
that's that's a surprising move going
back so why does that is a strong move
okay if rook d3 Bishop f5 if efore you
can do bishop takes e4 if rook III you
riding to Bishop h6 so this looks the
win material daddy like Queen takes
anyone is coming either win the knight
or Klee takes a one now Matt is now this
position is still quite imbalance it's
all night two pawns for the rook you can
argue for both sides there the ends who
coordinates better yep
yeah white has a pawn for the two points
of the exchange
on both sides of the board and a strong
square on v6 black would love to play a
move like b6 there everybody but
immediately you'd have to worry about
things like 95 with with tactics on the
diagonal so Magnus plays rook b8 and
he's gonna try to undermine this outpost
square on d6 with a move like b6 as soon
as he can but initially you know this
Bishop is this Bishop on g2 is causing
problems for that
I agree like when I first looked at I
didn't realize those two pawns in a
knight this is a position I think most
blitz players would take white because
practically speaking you sort of the
rooks aren't great at all I mean they
need mean open files the Knights have
outposts I mean that d6 is great at the
other night can like go to c3 to d5
White's pieces are better than the box
rooks right now and I think that's why
White has more than enough compensation
you'd love to play a 3b for his weight
in terms of an objective so let us find
the c5 Square and also using your
majority yep and immediately there may
be tactics on b7 here if if white wants
another pawn you could probably capture
it and then gobble your piece back with
Bishop takes c6
I don't expect Wesley to do that because
likely likely that actually would have
yeah and he doesn't but but here comes
the knight to d4 Eric right we like this
idea of a c6 I'm gonna do it maybe
potentially Bishop takes c6 and then 94
you know you know you got better that
outpost on d4 is permanent and also c6
is such a big weakness that why it would
be positionally winning so a6 Bishop c6
BC 694 I love white there I still like
white a lot and white may still go for
that exact type of idea take on c6 and
put the pony on d4 and indeed he does
you know give up the exchange here
Brooke takes d6 and try to draw you can
do route 66 our first Bishop before
preparing route 66 55 but then there's
maybe e4 you have to be careful yes
because if rook 6 takes and Bishop takes
e4 everybody white has 96 nice very nice
now this is this is definitely Wesleyan
control yeah could be a huge moment in
the match here we highlighted Wesley
needing to strike back already down by
two games with huge odds being being
favored favoring the world champion win
this match
this is this has been a this has been a
great game from start to finish
bye Wesley so Wesley handled the tactics
and this very aggressive approach that
Magnus and now he finds himself in a
close to winning position all he needs
to do is make sure his king is safer I'd
love to play f3 and g4 for my king not
only chopping blocks bishop but getting
my king off the back rank and slowly but
surely pushed these queens head pawns
down the board yeah I almost feel like
it's just the way in case you ever worry
about a back ranked issue but he doesn't
even think so though because he controls
the sea foul and the knight on d4 blocks
the default so Wesley's comfortable just
pushing this through yeah this is a big
one he needs this he needs is a three to
one right now and this has been a very
consistent game the player is by the way
they do play quickly Danny these are
both uh I mean I don't know what we're
on pace for here I know initially our
our match prediction said thirty games
which by the way is on the higher side
so that's not a surprise or our average
or our algorithm and metrics predict
that the average games played in these
matches Eric is 28 that's what we've had
overall but this get this match was
predicted to have up to 30 games played
so and right now they're on pace for
that as Magnus just resigns doesn't want
to try to hold and they will they will
go at it again right now with 49 minutes
left here in our first portion if you're
just joining us thanks for spending your
Saturday your weekend with it's kind of
a rare weekend match we normally do
these things in the middle of the week
so for all those who always wanted a
weekend here you go Magnus Carlsen is up
3-2 here in the five-minute portion the
speech Chess Championship brought to you
by master class alright Eric we find our
true fans when they got the option to go
to a party right or you know Saturdays
when you weed out right the men from the
boys right they wouldn't be spending a
Saturday with us Eric if they didn't
really love us yeah
oka uh another Carol another small edge
for white but also you know a totally
solid position for black
yeah Wesley's definitely prepared the
Carol for this match
and he's gotten very playable positions
so he just needs to improve on his last
game where he was doing quite well and
and blundered
so his openings openings are not not the
issue right now and it is a very close
match so so far I guess you could say
wes is doing doing pretty well he just
needs to convert his chances a little
bit more and this and then we're looking
at a very even match I'm uh you know
these positions for y-you you double on
the e-file you're not gonna break this
this structure I have seven to d5 so
what you try to do is try under Maya on
the other side potentially this h4 move
you might actually follow up with with
g4 because blocks very solid but he
doesn't have any brakes you know he
doesn't have e5 you don't one break he
does have his b5 the minority attack but
on the Kings side white sort of has some
flexibility there and some options so I
think he's he is gonna try to play 44
yeah and especially with this rook being
lifted to the third-ranked it has sort
of both nasty intentions potentially of
coming to h3 and defensive minded
intentions keeping an eye on the c3 pawn
this is structure you normally see where
we're with codes reverse from the Queens
gambit declined right Eric where you
have black may be thinking about Kings
side attacks and white launching this
minority attack and for the fans who
don't know pawn structures is deeply the
whole point of this move b4 is white
doesn't have good choices if black takes
it this pawn is weak if you take it then
the d4 pawn becomes weak so Wesley's
getting traditional counter play on the
Queen side in this pawn structure but
here goes the rook to h3
and this is gonna go all in here with h5
coming soon because he's not gonna be
type to just allow c3 to be the weakness
that Wesley can just jump on so he's got
a some kind of play here
and he's done well Danny when things are
being complicated so the last game is a
very good sign for Wesley that was a
complicated opening he handled it well
yell played Magnus in that that's that's
often yeah he's being vulnerable there
so yeah he's got another opportunity
yeah the position is is close to equal
and uh and I like this sort of building
up on this tension here and not not
making any clear decisions yet about
what he wants to see I don't see any
breakthrough for right here sort of
provoked a mistake here I think black is
doing just fine talk about why white
doesn't want to play the move f4 instead
of what he did with Knight f3 just for
the fans therefore just to to weakening
to the white knight weak to weakening
and it doesn't you're not trying to play
I have five there right i I just don't
like it it just weakens g44 permanently
and those those those are some key
squares later on right I don't think it
I think the downside said but but so now
you've got the position where White has
all of his pieces committed to the Kings
side so if he doesn't come up with
something it's not hard yeah there you
go Wesley brings in more pieces to the C
file at some point look for this pawn on
c3 to become a make or break thing here
for whether or not black has winning
chances block would love to play ninety
four here Danny
attacking the c3 pawn freeing up this
night but there are some issues with the
f7 pawn well Magnus correctly plays
Queen f3 or work F through Cunha three
makes more sense because the Queen's did
about and and I'm not the a bishop d8 is
a good move you want to play ninety four
you want to free that up yeah you know
one the future to guard the f7 pawn yeah
everybody this could be played at some
point because if G takes the intermezzo
is to take f6 first and then gobble the
H pawn and if Knight takes honestly I
don't know what to do on Knight takes
we're gonna find out he's gonna put you
for it okay and he's just gonna go for
the go for the H file amazing he's gonna
play g4
look at this transition Eric after rook
takes e4 Knight f6 is queen h1 just
lights out on h8 yeah yes
no there's King Fe okay so the King can
get out but but this is the idea
Magnus's I'm not sure he wants that the
Quidditch
he's actually just like maybe just keep
it I was gonna say yeah just kinky
pervert one yeah yes because the queen
is so good here because now you have
measured the king wearing the G while
there's this g5 move the knight moves in
the night takes g6 or some sort of
penetration on the Kings side so it's
gonna be very hard for black to keep the
balance g5 yes yeah I want to stop do
five and you'd love to play a king of a
king e7 and that is the current thing
that they're both calculating if Magnus
wins this game daddy this will be very
very impressive I think f3 is what he's
going to go for I'm expecting to see f3
here
well this move h5 I mean it kind of came
to a bit of surprise to both you and I
and and I think Wesley because the
willingness to sacrifice that pawn to
open the H file even though it was
clearly an idea on the board it was
interesting that white could just go
straight forward for that and look at
this here comes the other rook to h1 and
now if you run the King though the White
Queen can eventually take on g5 and and
we've got a huge you can actually do it
right now because the king is safe on g3
this is lost oh wow
this is live if flat gives any checks
everybody
Magnus just tucks it in to g3 and
everybody's safe
Wesley again looking looking around the
room looking for help as many people do
when they play Magnus Carlsen this is
just this is just not enough after rook
takes White's gonna play Queen takes g7
don't be surprised if Wesley just
resigns here Queen 67 everybody the maid
on f7 is coming if rook FA Dwight has
Knight to g6 the pawn is pinned to the
king look at the amount of time they
spent he still got 3 minutes and 40
seconds to conduct such a successful
attack especially when you know faced
with a pretty tough for passive endgame
very impressive the range yep by Magnus
with this one as you see the clock
ticking away there you can always tell
who has the upper hand when players of
this level meet up guys all the fans
here because these guys don't take time
unless unless they have to
and here what's the play Queen 87 check
in case white plays King edge through
but after 94 sorry after King g3 94
okay peppers v6 but but Rakesh yeah
rotation six comes and yeah it should
still be the attack continues rook takes
six is right now it takes c6 takes Queen
takes f8 is the idea everybody yeah he's
looking for something better than that I
don't blame him looking for something
better than Brooke takes c6 he could
just bring the Queen back to g5 I guess
and then if he forces f6 Queen g5 f 6 as
their queen back to g7 and Bob's your
uncle every night the Knights Knights on
you come yeah the Queen Hank there you
go
there there might be a rook h7 check
there the thing is white doesn't blacks
non-threatening another check so white
has multiple moves here he doesn't get
to me it right now he's got he's got a
full extra move so you can cash in the
throat a c6 if you don't see anything
otherwise play Queen g5 is you
recommended and then I have six and you
don't like Queen each for I guess just
back the Queen up and then go back to
Brooke h7 or night g6 both of them would
be threats on the board
so yeah I'm imagining Queen takes g5
I'm sorry Queen g5 check is gonna be
played yeah and he goes for it oh and
that's a simple way to transition into
an endgame so the exchange
oh that is that is strong so looks like
Queen c1 here Danny
oh I want you to show me the mid so
Queen someone h7 notice Queen age no
quit in 1787 that's very nice and then
he didn't see it here comes Queen age 77
I cover d7 though with Queenie for ah
okay yeah I did so Queen a for Wesley
did see it you'll have to visit lady
everybody's like even if you don't see
the mate is that black is not
threatening a check so you can he can
spend some time now and figure it out
there's not that pressure of a perpetual
so many options here but Magnus is gonna
take the physician Wesley's not making
any mistakes gonna get into position was
that was the issue but it is putting up
some good resistance here yeah
I'm not seeing a mate in every single
line I'm getting close to bear Motsinger
made
well maybe Wesley sees it look at this
nice move Queen to be won
that's the computer level that's a
computer type move right it's just you
and I are so focused there on the
kingside computers don't have any bias
from where they made just from the clean
Queen b5 what Queen c1 or nice and then
9 a 7
so Queen takes c6 Queen B check Queen C
a queen DS Queen b6 yep very nice
there's Queen b6 check 97 and Queen d6
very nice so Queen c7 check is what he's
gonna play here but that losses after
rook see 797 Queen B a check just
amazing I want to give a shout out to
all the members playing guess the move
currently on chess calm I think I just
saw it
username deepmind a1 you just took first
there with 13 out of 21 moves guessed
correctly if you want to play guess the
move log onto chess calm and see if you
can play like Magnus Carlsen well
speaking of Magnus Carlsen and Wesley
cells chances Eric I think the body
language of both players kind of says
where the match is at this point in its
in its stage right I mean what uh yeah
what a counter punch by Meghan is Wesley
played a very good game got his first
win that's a definite confidence builder
and then he gets sat right up and sat
down like without one that was like
getting mated like that you know the
Carol Kane has a reputation for being a
very very solid opening it's very
impressive what just happened
absolutely and what do we expect to
happen here and and now uh this is the
first time we've seen this open and
Wesley sticking with this night of
freebie 3 e3 I guess officially a collie
system now but but at some point what
are you thinking a match like that I
know you've you've again you've had a
lot of long blitz sessions at some point
what's the balance between being
stubborn and sticking to your guns
because you prepared this system which I
think it looks like Wesley did he's gone
to with several times with white and
then recognizing that it's time for a
new approach and try to mix it up what
would be your thoughts on that
well in Wesley's case I think you should
mix it up if you've prepared properly I
find when I go and tilt and I try to mix
up my openings things get even worse
okay mindset you're coming from but you
can objectively sort of evaluate how how
your blood schemes are going which is
easier said than done
then then yeah you can you can make that
transition Wesley he plays a wide range
of openings so he's very capable of
getting decent positions in other lines
um but but I don't think there's a panic
button yet not yet no yeah it's it's for
two that's that's manageable well as we
talk about the the different segments
and how how this match was predicted
here that we see 35 minutes left in the
5 minute segment everybody to remind you
right after this is 3 to blitz but in
our in our preparation and in those
stats Eric we actually predicted that
the 3:2 portion would potentially be the
the best portion for Wesley so with our
algorithm saying he may only be about a
game worse than Magnus in that time
control so you're right if you can stay
within a couple games perhaps he he
gives himself a chance to get a big
score in the three-minute portion yeah I
mean the one area where I'm not good at
predicting the idea is how people are
gonna do the chess960 and that's that's
something we talked about people giving
up their parties on Saturdays to be with
us actually Foreman in the chat correct
says he's at a party watching chess
maybe it's a chess party so we are the
party Eric I want to see I want to see
proof I want to see I want to eat it I
want to see people around and I want to
see the guy sitting on his couch with
his phone oh right just watch but not
alone not alone a lot of big social
environment we want we want every we
want drinks in hand and the party is on
with Magnus Carlsen on the big TV also
Brandon Laughlin asks at chess if it
wasn't for Magnus Carlsen in this
generation like take Magnus out of the
picture of all the best players in the
world who do we predict would be the
world champion right now I don't know
maybe Anand would still be the world
champion but I think you got to say
Wesley so and Fabiano Caruana or right
there you know but it's a hard question
to say because even guys like a car or
Nakamura are super talented but has
really struggled against someone like
Magnus so I think
I think it would change change belts
sort of quite a bit I think I think
we're in a really strong generation and
yeah and there's negative stands oh but
actually otherwise it's you can see guys
like Aronian you know his own Ian of
course yeah but but he might not be
consistent enough to like maintain that
oh you never know there's a lot of guys
in that right below Magnus there's like
five six players so you could you could
make a good argument for it I think it
would change change hands yeah it's a
great point thanks for those questions
there from Braden Laughlin and Foreman
and everybody in both chat rooms please
keep your questions coming and thanks
for watching
all right Eric this is getting crazy we
have double connected pass pawns for
white and double connected pass pawns
for black how do you evaluate something
like this that's a great question good
question
[Music]
to me it seems balanced that's really
what I can say because I the players
were playing with such confidence there
I guess based on the time you can make a
comment that probably Magnus is doing
well here because we preparing the sign
and along he's along these D structures
right that's why he allowed maintenance
stuff so much space because this he
allows him to take f6 um Wesley doesn't
want it yeah he's got the option taking
up six the problem is that dark square
bishop is the blockading bishop so if
you give up your dog for a bishop that's
white you'll never challenge blacks
block it right that's a saviours why
Magnus he's keeping that [ __ ] money
five as a threat it's keeping that
knight on c3 honest because they'd love
to push those bonds or like whose pawns
get mobilized first right and right now
it looks like Magnus because he's
threatened and played D for right now
right
d4 is is a winning threat so like I like
black he seems to be quicker to the
punch d 4 and D 3 may be coming and
because of that Wesley decides he has to
really mix it up does the thing we said
he probably shouldn't now look for all
of these dark squares to become this 99
problems and the dark squares are some
we're gonna play f5 here and then
because if D form right now which I
would love to play there might run into
94 I play f5 maybe I can follow up with
d4 I'm looking at news like that
interesting and you point out that the
Queen can't take it because then the
knight would be hanging on c3 so I like
that move Erika 5 would be
would be a really nice shot to strangle
the e4 square and make D for an official
threat and Magnus place it I love it
when you guess Magnus is moves but it
just makes me feel so good to be right
alongside you I know that makes you feel
weird but when you play better Magnus
out of all the players all commenting on
will often logically find moves out I
don't and and make me look so well I
think a lot of people feel that way
including opponents but that is good
it's good is he's pushing pushing about
his level and that's the ceiling is is
going going on
so d4 not yet because the c4 pawn is
hanging and that was one of the reasons
Wesley backed up with the night but
right moves like even just rook a to c8
might be as simple enough to threaten
default right one of those cases where
connected passed pawns can can win a
piece can material so black is willing
to potentially even lose upon if you can
like at d4 get c3 rolling down the board
right now there's no big threat by white
his pieces are on the back rank only
thing he has right now Dani is the
knight in Queen on the Kings side as
long as Magnus can control that it's up
to him he's actually just winning this
is such this is such a passive position
for black for white I mean when you
really look at it yep the rooks are
terrible the knight is boxed out on d1
that's one thing about four right just a
team he took took away that III Square
from the knight some the NBL defense
team by boxing 9 8 r d1 this is this is
like I don't know what Queen g7 Queen
yourself okay there's a little idea of
97 here trying to like put the net on
Essex which you'd even play Knight g7 if
you wanted to get the Queen okay but
Queen g7 makes the most sense I think to
get the Queen back on that diagonal
we're on g7 she both defends the King
side and still has her eye over here
everyone which is gonna help when these
two pawns start pushing up the board so
so I like it I agree yeah rook d8 and
Magnus was very patient with his pawns
Eric but in the end there they are gonna
get going here I can we can talk about
that they've transitions before that to
just the better position for Magnus
because he can he kept his connect upon
and white lost them now it's
transitioning again to just an exchange
up both sides have connected pawns
Wesley may have blundered there but it's
not the worst blunder because his
position is easier to play now this is
like in common well it makes me wonder
if it even was a blunder honestly like
right after he played it because he kind
of played it so quickly rook b5 I I
wonder if he said well my best chance
would be a transition so that at the
very least now white is the one with
some threats and right why does the
initiative and and before I was just the
one way street so here Magnus is the one
who has to find some defensive moves
first on some precision the issue still
is that this Bishop on f1 is a
non-factor this man on b1 is a
non-factor and it's hard to imagine that
to connect two pawns and whites
remaining pieces will will be all just
wandering he played c7 he just forgot
the bishop was guarding the rook and oh
no magnet sticks rook takes b6 yeah
there's just the Queen the rook goes to
c8 the Queen goes f8 and black has
enough but oh my god shaking his head
chuckling a little bit I think he might
be shaking his head because I think he
may have missed something as well and
then Wesley missed something so kind of
laughing at the luck of the luck of how
that position end up being a win for him
but either way Carlsen now back up to
three games in the lead to the lead that
is a big lead now Dani is when I would
start considering switching up my
openings as Wesley next time I play
white that was that those are a couple
losses with white and well it's because
you made a great point Erik highlighting
that Magnus wasn't even down on time for
a second right so it's not even just
he's out playing him in the opening but
Magnus was up almost two and a half
minutes on the clock at one point in
that game which which tells you he's
more than comfortable against Wesley's
prep and it might be time to change
gears yep yep yep that's a good move I
think that clears clears up a lot of
things so DD 3d for little little sassy
transition here and our take off to a
check maybe they played I mean this is
something that looked at
they both thought they were playing
theory we're gonna find out in a move or
two and I think we're gonna find out
that white is actually gonna end up up
the piece here so I think what does he
thought he was playing a line he had
looked at and Magnus was all prepared
was 94 the tactics worker you're
attacking he's fine
the point everybody's at black trades on
e4 white gets this Bishop away from the
attack with tempo just gobbling back the
piece on e4 and somehow being up a miner
at the end of it so I'm very dangerous
territory right now where Magnus is
building some momentum magazine doing
what he does classic Magnus being Magnus
well Wesley's gonna be all-in but here
comes Knight takes f6 but check and then
I mean how can how can Knight takes f6
and then just back the bishop up to e4
not be just fine for what just just
winning just a piece up with okay that's
really not not in any danger on f1
there's no Knights on the board it's
those buckos yes but that night on III
but otherwise that King is perfectly
safe on f1 and you're gonna enjoy that
extra piece and box King also has its
own issues well and we're learning
desire why why nobody wants to play
Magnus Carlsen at chess right awful
another again maybe he'll play go next
time but I mean this is this is just so
tough Wesley we know is one of the
absolute the cream of the crop as far as
strong grandmasters go but in this
format in the blitz format and the
performances we've already seen Magnus
Carlsen put up and beat hick are
knocking more last year in the final
that's exactly why our predictions said
what they did about these about these
players and and we can see there that
the the match odds right now with 27
minutes left greatly favored Magnus
Carlsen at this point Eric the opening
the opening was changed slightly on
right we've now got a Wesley's a strong
theoretician and he's known you know as
as very dangerous with white like he
gets good positions even among the top
players he's not getting that he's made
and that's I'm a little surprised by
that I'm a little surprised by that that
maybe you tried you for like I'm looking
at ya I tend to agree and I and I think
that it's one of those things that
online chess when you play so casually
has you thinking okay like I know that
there's some blitz openings I want to
play but you know when these guys come
prepared and there's a lot of money on
the line and and they're in good form I
mean I think your best chance is to beat
someone like Magnus would be to use your
highest level of preparation you know I
mean at a certain point you've got to be
able to challenge him in the main lines
and see if you can catch him that's
where he's been vulnerable I mean if you
could say volume never bold wise
openings are still exceptional but he's
been caught before and he's better than
everyone else and you I think is what
makes Magnus the world champion and
better than some of his peers is not in
the opening phase it's the middlegame
phase I mean a lot of other factors but
in the opening he shouldn't be getting
as good positions as he's gotten today I
guess if I like Leslie players shifting
around we're losing sight of them we've
got Magnus's mouth meets Wesley's hair
we've also been told by one of our
statisticians that the record number of
games so far in a speeches championship
match if you're wondering was 31 but
this match is currently on pace for 32
total games given that when these guys
are plundering they seem to kind of just
resign Eric right I mean we're seeing
we've seen a lot of quick games this
will be game number 9 in the have we had
a draw yet yes we had two draws okay two
draws so far but but of the games we've
had two draws and everything else
decisive yeah I mean they played sharp
positions and and we're seeing that well
Magnus is doing well he's handling
mostly sharp positions broccoli he did
lose that one game wisely played
fantastic chess but yeah we were seeing
that people are watching or wondering
why Wesley resigned let's see two games
ago he's on a piece it's like yeah I
mean he wants to he wants to play more
games and he really trusts the Magnus
his ability to convert there right and I
probably agree without a coach I don't
think that position was one
where he realized he had chances to come
back and might as well live to fight
another day but you put yourself in
Wesley's shoes right now and you have to
find some way to recover like even in
your in your head it's already very
tough because he's played man everyone
knows what maybe this is about how how
consistent he is how how good he is when
he's got the lead and and how can you
just change the momentum here the tencel
is a match well here we've got a game
that I think Black has managed to get
get a fine position out of the opening
all the tactics are a little weird right
now
once these positions as I would say with
black I don't have any criticisms with
white yeah I think you have to switch it
up but the black is getting playable
positions and he can't complain too much
we're seeing another position here well
man this is probably to keep the Queen's
on the mornings you're probably gonna
try to use the space given by this e 5
pawn to forget some pressure on the
Kings side the only issues black has in
the position is his lack of development
on the Kings side and if you play e6 to
try to get the bishop on f8 out maybe
there's ideas of the night coming to e4
and then d6 is a potential target so I
agree Wesley's position seems fine but
he does have something to figure out
right now on the Kings side and here he
he plays e6 but I expect 94 from Magnus
and yeah he plays it I I kind of like
white in these structures I feel like
they're they're deceptively dangerous
when you've got this pawn on e5 d6 is
weak maybe the lights card sorry not the
light square bishop the white bishop
comes to g5 and makes it hard to put the
darts for Bishop on e7 without trading
and d6 so am i overestimating White's
potato for an edge and here though he's
playing these moves right normally I
would say yes but Magnus is playing
pretty confidently normally I'd say like
yeah I got nothing wrong in this block
I'm super stalling are graded on d5 but
I'm one move behind
I'd love to hide you should be 7 before
you I don't see how to get that so in
this specific position I would have to
agree with you that there is annoying
pressure that white is going to
get on the dark squeeze right why don't
you make a great point yeah if you just
make two two differences here everybody
just take that light that white bishop
and put it anywhere else even on d2 and
and give black advisors and if anyone's
better black is completely solid
structure and the e5 pawn might even be
overextended but here as it is it's it's
white posing some tough development
questions now to black because where
does that dark square bishop go without
without letting d6 become available or
creating some other problems
the bishop before just a3 yeah suddenly
Magnus makes simple positions look a
little more dangerous I mean I might be
crazy by the way but g5 could be plated
one of these days it might not work
right away there may be some sort of
Queen takes Knight us yeah but yeah no I
know you were thinking with the knight
who did that oh why does just simply uh
don't just the plunder just now the
transition they were full white White's
gonna just have an attack for free
blacks King is stuck in the center he's
not cancelling anymore
y can always play Bishop g3 if the g5
becomes an issue but I'm expecting a
Magnus to win pretty soon here or at
least at least win a pawn or something
this is the king that just stuck there
with all the heavy pieces on the board
it's hard to criticize I mean yes Knight
f4 was a blunder here everyone you can
see it on the analysis board after this
nice little discovered check the Magnus
plate which opened up the Queen to hit
the knight but you know when you're in
tough positions you make blunders that's
that's literally a chess tree all right
and Magnus had the pressure it became a
deceptively difficult position for black
to complete his development and now now
he's paying the price like you said the
king is gonna be under fire for the rest
of the game which in blitz especially
like maybe a computer holds this
position as black with long time
controls although even that I doubt but
but here in blitz with a king on e7 this
is just so hard this is a we're starting
to see game after game though about a
minute and a half time edge for Magnus
in most positions and yes I also doing
well but this he's one they just threw
the last game but before that three wins
I wrote for Magnus and it's just
building out
here this is just the risk free position
gonna double up on the D file he's gonna
keep this Queen age for a check in his
pocket I mean because black is gonna
have to challenge the D file at some
point but it doesn't do anything in
Queen h4 is gonna hurt so this is this
is lost of Brooksie - maybe the ripped D
- no Rick C - look see - maybe your idea
of Queen h4 check first and then Queen
over to f4 just kind of huh yep
that's open you might go Queen a 4 right
right away but rookie yeah I was gonna
say your initial suggestion rook t2 is
maybe I'm fine - just I initially
thought there's Queen takes b2 here now
I quickly realized Queen h4 here should
be crushing because now you can't even
play f6 anymore everybody dude yeah
thank you not but he just played it
anyways because like he's demoralized
like I think that he saw this this is
witty for for white I think Wesley saw
this but he's just a moralized like this
is this is bad we take two taking a
breath there you can see he leans back
knows he's frustrated and that's what he
has to do he's got to gather himself and
deliver that fighters that fighters
punch he's got a he's got a punch back
at this point he sticks with the opening
Eric and I I think we're both a little
critical of that potentially thanks to
Lee Prince who just cheered and gave it
here 2001 bits I think on on twitch I
think that's what it is I assume he's
cheering for the match but if anybody
needs a big cheering squad right now I
think it is Wesley this is this is a
worse start than I would have predicted
that seven and a half to two and a half
I mean yeah in fact I've just never seen
Magnus lose the match where he's been
ahead I mean just in any format well
currently max is sorry
currently Magnus is over performing our
pre match prediction there and for those
who are wondering what is our algorithm
going to release about how we see the
next couple of matchups that are that
are gonna be gonna be happening in this
features championship I will say real
quick that you may have some shocking
news revealed about Sergey Karjakin
versus Takara Nakamura in terms of who
we predict as favorite in that match
Eric but I'll leave I'll leave you to
wonder interesting is stuff can't wait
for that but
course we're focused right now Magnus
versus so we have another ready
positioned that again it's fine for
white it's not that white doesn't have
an edge here but Magnus is just playing
very fast and also very comfortable with
blacks plans and the way he should
approach these positions yeah the the
nice thing at least in this position for
Wesley it's a bit more controlled and
it's not as sharp and he's not allowing
you know all these like passed pawns and
in the start he's changing it up but
this is this is where we always find
ourselves anyway we just ask ourselves
how can this player change change the
current momentum against Magnus it's
it's that question that pops up every
single time we've covered him it's like
where do you get him uncomfortable
I really he's not making any mistakes
just gives me flashbacks right nobody
stay with us don't go exactly exactly
I'm getting some flash back to the board
or something it's getting a little tough
here all right well Wesley what's he's
doing okay here he's got that right no
he's got the Nancy for he wants to
solidify that which means you have to
control the deep on so you did that with
with E 4 E 5 can always be met by let's
say taking and but black has the B file
to work with and you can play ok d5 also
runs it to Knight takes d5 so yes on a
good day you want to play a 4s white and
Bishop c3 you have all your pawns on
light squares are gonna pick up the e5
pawn and life is good so Magnus does
have to go for something active here if
Knight takes e5 maybe Queenie six
something along the lines of that or
yellow or he's giving that he's given
items giving it up straight in
I guess well it's strange again white
just play Bishop takes e7 and then I
take on d3 check and then I take on c7
okay so tactically this works for Magnus
I was gonna say even a move like working
one just yeah no matter what you're
taking on d3 so what I would like to do
is play King g1 here just get off that
back rank I guess is the transposition
either way we're gonna see what you said
edie three king g1 Queen takes c7 Queen
takes d3 White's a tiny
better because black has weak c5 and 85
points but but nothing nothing more than
a microscopic edge for white here
shout-out to horndog 16 who just
subscribe to us on twitter v / chest
thank you for that yeah the problem is
white also has a weakness b3 right that
pony I'd rather be on a3 would rather be
back on a2 so at least you can focus on
sevogda here now this this is this is a
position where Wesley has to try because
it's the best decision he's beaten in a
few games but this is actually probably
endeavor at skis or black just puts a
rock on the second-ranked pressures up
to keep Sorokin f1 passes and he can he
can just scoop up that pond on a four by
double teaming it shout-out to mr.
twitch usually immerse Africa immerse
Africa who just subscribe to us only 15
minutes left in the 5 minute portion and
then we'll move to the the segment where
I think Wesley after a quick break will
make some noise and maybe maybe melt a
little bit of a comeback the question is
always what happens when when bullet is
on the board but here Wesley is just
gonna push the pawns a little bit again
I think that playing a position that
psychologically he knows he can't really
lose for a little bit might not be able
this one gonna be a draw this one's
gonna be draw quickly he does not have
that extra pawn like but from a match
strategy I guess even even though
psychologically he's happy he's not
losing this from a match strategy you
kind of just want to draw this game and
run another chance you know yeah the one
thing to make sure is okay you know
pretty draw yeah yeah the West is the
type of player he respects Magnus a lot
some would say maybe too much for a
rival right he's not going to be trying
to play play that out they know like he
knows like where he's gonna catch
Magnussen and he's okay
getting that but it's not oh yeah it's
gonna be in some of these complex milla
games Magnus has blundered he's you know
he loses games yep okay this reminds me
of the protest thing I think what fine
goal against Carlsen oh my god you
remember that game where I was I was
calling a blunder by Magnus and looked I
looked like a bigger fool than I
normally do that was that was ridiculous
well - plays King one and chosen it's
very easy to
to me that yeah well especially if you
just don't know the line right I mean
and this did he had this this happen to
the protest like everybody where Ben
Feingold got this exact position you see
right here on the analysis board and and
Anna Rudolph and I were calling bull
under coffee else blunders by Magnus and
we were just totally wrong so position
by the way seems very like again Magnus
repeating this shows that he thinks the
line is totally fine yeah it looks good
it's good for why I like the two bishops
now I like white I mean White has the
two bishops you're gonna swing the rook
to c1 he does it before I can highlight
it he's like more defined and yeah white
is totally comfortable a minority attack
is coming we need to move for black
Danny because like if castles we know
exactly what's gonna happen and unlike
the game we saw before we're bangus one
when he faced the minority attack your
blacks not setup at all yeah any kind of
play on the Kings side that game
everybody was the game where the
structure was reversed and Magnus
flipped the rook to h3 and then sacked
the H pawn if you remember to launch an
awesome attack so that was the structure
Eric was referring dude this is that
exact same pawn structure but with the
colors reversed and even though 94 is
Wesley's best try that's a typical
maneuver here to try to to try to do
exactly that Eric is gonna want to open
up lines and here you go you see the
pieces coming to the side of the board
this is just a yeah but it's not nearly
what the other one was because black
does black doesn't have nearly enough
pressure and Oh black is black is uh to
me just worse here yep the King on e2 is
an asset it's not on the light square
it's totally safe you can put the bishop
back on d3 try to play for b5 but look
at you see black Starks for a bishop and
you look at white side squared bishop
the light square bishop is a
significantly better has some has some
space right now has some diagonals the
bishop h4 has no you need a break for
block and where's your break to f2 is
not a target III is not a target to too
too solid here and he's gonna have to
like well I hear at least he's got the a
pawn may put the bishop back on e7 and
put a B for you
right now I like white because I do
prefer I can even consider Queen c2 and
try to infiltrate to the c7 c7 square
penetration along the seventh rank is
everybody's favorite rank to penetrate
so Magnus was gonna tuck the King on to
g2 he's actually gonna tackle the King
side I wouldn't even be surprised an e2
c g4 g5 coming up he's also gone and I
wonder about this last approach I do I
do think that bringing the Queen to c2
and being more aggressive just
simplifying might have been better for
white but okay Magnus is okay he's
playing both sides of the board she is
with h5 benefit of it is you're pretty
much keeping blacks King boxed in and
also preventing the move g6 so a bishop
is also staying on f5 there are some
downsides though let's see what happens
I think Wesley is is unwinding I mean
suddenly there's a double threat here
here at Queen h3 check and the pawn on
b5 I mean I I know it seems safe and I
it's easy for us to assume Magnus had
the right plan but I actually I feel
like those last few moves were
unnecessarily maneuvering when maybe I
had better chances to just be aggressive
on the Queen side y h5 is a movie you
don't see may display too much because
not flexible
he might as well I kept that in his
pocket right you're right Magnus is
mister mister flexible is that a term
using chess I know we use it in you know
ballet and dance but mr. flexible if you
ever beheld that I've never been called
mr. flexible but I would definitely pay
to watch you host mr. flexible show and
just some stretching flexible stretching
right everyone loves a flexible partner
when they're working out all right well
the Queen comes to b6 b5 is potentially
hanging and I and I do believe that
Wesley has worked his way out of the
worst part of this game and this could
be a big turnaround Eric with only 9
minutes left right now watch this rook
if rook da he's gonna do Brooke takes e4
and he's gonna he's gonna sacrifice the
exchange that's what I'm calling I am
calling Rutina fives or yes yes
precisely shout-out to Swiss drummer boy
for just subscribing to us apparently he
enjoys flexible conversations Queen to
d6 of Wesley's
I'm not gonna let you sack get out that
was a cool idea that name is from yeah
very good read by Wesley yeah I'll go
now the games sharpen getting sharp I
have this sharp sure b5 is weak and why
not but blacks King is not as safe as
whites and there are some white square
issues here so I think it's very
important for black to get rid of this
light squared bishop
trade off some of these well pieces I'm
a little concerned here though for for
Wesley ninety-five is coming others no I
agree suddenly plan yeah if you don't
like might be six I think I think on the
analysis board I think he should have
played the Bishop f6 to guard the e5
square first before night to be six
because now here comes 95 at some point
for white well the thing is define I
said upon a for as I said fun this is
just a five-on-five pawn structure but
way better for white Magnus has it took
a while to recoup that b5 honor as you
said a never b6 is it's probably not as
well places it would be on the Kings
side because I think he's gonna need
some some more reinforcements there hey
here comes 95 I mean 95 will hit both
f7g cigar the move 94 is because he
didn't want to walk we know six stream
ah ok so rook looks nice but yeah 95
will come in short order here likely the
move the position plays itself here 95
is nicely flora booth threatening Knight
takes III check ooh
so so 94 is a move I will move my King
to let say g1 okay and then why is mine
yes but it's a it's a tricky move and it
has a threat okay he decides no silly
any tricks are for kids for me it's just
structurally oh now Bishop d3 is a big
threat here look at the evaluation bar
it slides up for white and Wesley sits
back in his chair this is oh sorry it
was three to two for Magnus now it's
gonna be nine to three wow what a shot a
6-1 run Wesley played Queen a eight
missing Bishop d3 the evaluation bar
shoots up the board
announces maton 11 for white and the
game is over that's a clippable moment
brought to you by grandmaster eric
hanson clip that melvin for his fans and
please share it on the twitch social
sphere that was by the way a really
impressive game by magnus because wesley
was was was coming back he was
pressuring this beef upon this Bishop d7
who was it was really a big time that
was really that whole concept was was
critical no you're right and i think he
had miss played the you know the
pressure had sort of flipped around but
Magnus does that sometimes where you
know even when you find yourself you
think you can be a little critical of an
approach he's creating even more
resources that will allow him to win and
outplay his opponents later on and
that's exactly what he did here with
this weird Bishop d7 imbalance and we
got that we got to have that highlight
able moment there with the bishop coming
back to d3 so and we see why that Pont
h5 was so useful
that's what cemented that light square
diagonal that game so even though the
Mumbai I questioned it paid off and it's
something Wesley underestimated that I
get my queen and Bishop on that battery
with that pawn h5 and there's no way for
you to challenge that diagonal so making
me look bad that's that's what he does
mm-hmm his favorite pastime
so now Bishop b4 check I would oh wait
no I could consider that if I want to
annoy my opponent there's annoying
Andy's in the crowd they should or queen
a queen a5 this is a better version of
that because if Queen needs yeah yeah
that's the better version volt Magnus is
just much better here the difference
between this and the last position is
the King is on you too but here it's an
open position here black doesn't lack
the two bishops White has an isolated
pawn everything is worse about this
position this is already old Magnus is
on his way he'll played probably just
Bishop e7 here maybe to guard the night
and then unless he really wants to mix
it up maybe he's not I was gonna say
maybe he's not afraid of Bishop takes f6
and he just develops and he does it
faster than I can say cuz this this is
yeah this is not even a real threat
because this King is safe you give up
the dark squared Bishop and why it's
gonna be just fine so well with five
minutes left everybody don't go anywhere
and likely at the end of this game if
this is the last one we will have
chess960 on the board
before we transition into the three to
blitz portion where I believe Wesley so
is gonna rebound I'm gonna go out on a
limb here Eric and to say despite what
is definitely gonna be a difficult
psychological break for Wesley knowing
it hasn't gone his way I think he's
gonna do better in the three-minute
portion I need more convincing Danny
because I'm looking at how big this is
handling the clock and it's just he's
just never down on time he's playing
quicker than Wesley so and and he's
beating Wesley I mean in a lot of let's
say sharp positions I don't see why that
would help based on what I've seen today
it might actually be worse because
Magnus is playing faster and better
three-minute portion you know that is
that famous video to week two so Magnus
says that he's been quicker he's playing
better and he's that that's a very
psychologically very tough thing to face
when you're playing someone yeah playing
better than you and quicker that's
that's so frustrating that's the
toughest like you're totally dominated
it you're better faster stronger Daft
Punk wrote the song about Magnus yeah I
agree but we'll see I think sometimes
the 3/2 portion is a different tempo
it's not exactly the same type of time
management right and it's also one of
those controls that what is it why is it
that most players prefer that I think
after bullet most players would rather
play 3-minute blitz than five-minute
blitz and I think that's true for you
why is that
I just online I just for some reason
like the like the quicker time controls
I can't see the chair that my my
attention span with all of the social
media distractions are just as short as
possible like I can't even sit still for
one minute thank you mark mark 25 for
subscribing Magnus is up upon but it is
obstacle Bishop so what are what are the
winning chances here as well I'm still
here because there's gonna be at least
one rook on the board and and that just
means he's up upon and he's gonna push
that this is this is okay ideally and I
just wants to target this f2 pawn I'm
expecting rook out for here but yeah
he's gonna he's gonna eyeball that okay
doesn't need to either way it's gonna be
a rockin Bishop you keep the Brooks on
the board and you play with that extra
extra pawn and just try to provoke a
weakness slowly improve your position
Magnus is his bread butter
let's see how he maximizes this he's not
gonna trade the slow grind the rooks
gonna flip over to the Kings side likely
black is gonna want to establish this
Bishop to c5 at some point use the
two-on-one majority and and yeah maybe
it's a draw with best play I think it
probably would be if a computer was
defending white against Magnus but not
everybody can defend like a computer
against Magnus Carlsen so we'll see
we'll see if we can hold this if I'm
going to look for ideal setup for black
here daddy
it's gonna be pawn to f5 bishop on c7 is
gonna go to d6 or summer central and c5
and put my king on on f6 I do want to
push those pawns but I want to do that I
can save that for later okay one thing
I'll say regarding what we just talked
about is like Wesley maybe has chances
of chess960 portion and and I think that
is like the must-win game to me I don't
see 3-minute changing unless he starts
off maybe well in the 960 yeah this is a
different game a little bit of a
different game a little bit for those of
you who don't know we have just about
10,000 of you watching right now
concurrent viewers thanks for being us
960 is random randomly set up pieces
also known as Fischer random a very
popular variant likely the most popular
and most respected variant outside of
classical chess in fact a match was just
announced that Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura will be throwing down in Norway
at some point in a chess960 match - in
early 2018 and did you know that we will
have our first-ever chess960 chess calm
Championship prize fun and date yet to
be announced but I can say early Eric
it'll be early I can say now it'll be
early January where we have a big chess
960 event here you can pretty much come
in yep so here we go rookie Joker is
coming to c5 f2 is a big problem so he's
played up ya know he's gonna like it
doesn't matter oh did he miss that
didn't get game over
I wonder if Wesley missed that or a
phone that is a little bit now it's game
over - connected past bonds Bishop c5
and e5 is coming I know that this is
this is a
well that game ends actually and there
is still 30 seconds left on the official
game clock that I have so I believe they
have one more game yes I'm gonna be told
we actually keep two we're so official
here we keep two clocks one that I
highlight for the show and entertainment
purposes and one that is officially run
by our score keeper so official
scorekeeper says that that actually was
the last five-minute game and we now
have chess960 on the board okay so
officially chess960 is underway magnus
assessing his setup here eric as white
he's assessing that he wants to start
with the C pawn and here we go
yeah this is the game this is the game
where I think capacity is gonna find a
point where you can turn turn the tables
it's going to be in the chest and at 16
that'll ask him even though there's a
blunder at the end I think that's a very
tough positionable yeah no I I agree it
was one of those positions that you just
hate you almost hate having obstacle
bishops there because you know you feel
like you have this expectation you
should go to hold and draw but Magnus is
just gonna poke and prod at all the
right weaknesses and it's so hard to
defend that all right well this is weird
early bishops traded on the long
diagonal this is why we love chess960
double bishop trade true that double
true how often you see the bishops come
off the board this early I'll move five
in chess 960 Eric bishop you're off the
board
no I yeah I mean having played too much
960 but this is uh this is a weird this
is definitely I'm guessing that this is
just a little bit preferable for white
just a slight I mean it's so symmetrical
just you got the extra move you get in
d4 yeah forget d4 Knight and c2 but I'm
looking I'm looking at this from blacks
perspective day I'm trying to find a way
for Wesley to come up with something he
needs this win so yeah I mean it's in a
symmetrical position no bishops no real
concrete weaknesses for either side to
speak of she thought g4 but my opponent
long before I want to put my apology for
his black it's all ahead on the square
like f3 and I don't think that'll be
allowed classic Eric always looking to
do something over there on the g-spot
alright let's move on and talk about the
fact that White's gonna prepare to play
4d for good yeah
d4 brick d1 o d4 first and rip d1 and
then we just have this well slightly
better position for white
Leslie maybe considering your your G
file area execution that you love over
there maybe the thing is you can really
predict what will happen if you just
fight in the center it's gonna be a very
right dry position where you know what
could happen after g5 is that even if
even if white doesn't play chief or you
might get f5 and Queen h5 or something
and really try to launch a space assault
that is what I'm dreaming about I don't
think it's objectively the best but I am
looking to to complicate things here the
knight comes to e7 we continue to have
pure symmetry this is a rare chess960
affair
okay the Brooks coming to d1 as we
predicted but I think you're right I
think if Wesley wants to create winning
chances he's got it will allow white to
get d4 and look for something dynamic on
the Kings side whether it's g4 g v h5
and h for something or okay wrecker oka
love that castles if you don't remember
that everybody that is illegal I often
forget that everybody does yeah we had
two interesting chess960 games when
Nakamura played Caruana a couple of
weeks ago where we had some really
really exciting kind of castles king
flipping from one side of the board of
the other well he's trying to get the
Knight to e5 be met by Queen e2 so now
white can castle right yep well this is
just a Marathi sure that should be very
favorable of stockfish didn't understand
that
why should castle there because the
evaluation bar after castle slid way up
for white as if it wasn't even
considering it as a candidate move this
is after
Castle it's like the the mask has been
taken off and and what's being revealed
is an extremely beautiful position for
white in terms like Magnus this is just
way better for white you got full
control you covered b5 you covered defy
the two brakes this is this is a
comfortable comfortable edge whenever
the face more than edge this is this is
really bad for Wesley this is like I
agree form right there that that's like
whenever someone puts an outpost square
on you're sick strength or further it's
like having a little toys or shoe this
is what is thinking like that there's no
coming back
this is very like you know you why does
choices between moves like f-4e for even
knight a for here I think white why can
kind of pick the way he wants to expand
on the D fun he goes for efore I like
that one better than F for a little more
direct this is hard to watch like as
soon as the casting happened in this
stuff as I oh no this is this is this is
a mangas position are our own P is
active in the chat on chest comm you can
log into chest comm slash live or just
click that button right below the chest
TV player and you'll instantly be taken
into live already following Magnus and
Wesley so but people asking Pete if he's
Peter doggers and Pete says I'm not
Peter doggers and Peter doggers as much
better looking so thanks for that
clarification Pete be for Eric this is
rough Wesley needs to take a break he
needs to shake it off take a deep breath
and come back for some three two action
here you and I will well will we be
looking at an 11-3 lead that's the
question right a 7-game advantage as it
stands and it could be eight before this
chess960 game is over and this does is
it this isn't even a chess960 game you
know what this is right this is now a
hedgehog right a hedgehog gone wrong for
Flanders the Hedgehog yes this is this
is a hedgehog which is not a position
and and I actually had this like a
hydraulic structure I was playing it
along against Magnus and that's where
yeah he went on a 13 on run against me
in our blitz match is when I started
liking the Hedgehog and he manages space
better than anyone
yeah I'm just just maximize these
positions so well so they're just what's
gonna happen is he's a bit of a ball
constructor position he doesn't need to
find a break through his moves are just
much easier to find when she's gonna be
lower and lower on time and a certain
point is gonna break just isn't gonna
have no time and no more space left he's
gonna just be suffocated
thanks for Mike hunt 69 69 69 for
subscribing to twitch we have confirmed
now that the record number of games in
the 5g portion previous to this Eric was
11 guess what game number we're on right
now this is game 14 they just shattered
the record of 5-2 games and in today so
it was 11 previously this is the 14th
5+2 game we've had today that doesn't
bode well for Wesley because honestly
yeah I mean the more games they're
playing right now and it's one of the
reasons why I think Magnus is tipping
the scales even further in the direction
beyond our match prediction of where he
might be favored to win he's currently
on pace to win this match by a score of
23 and a half to 10 and a half of it
stays like this I would I would argue
it's gonna be even worse than that
like that let me not argue that's my
feeling but yeah I mean if it means
there's been a lot of quick losses or
losses where there's a lot of time in
the clock in this position I'm attracted
to Queen III because I stopped f4 I
protect my knight on c3 you know I also
take all this b6 square classic Eric
looking for the right tickle spots but
Queen yeah here here he's just saying
what you can take on c3 but I can take
on c6 and my king is way safer and your
structures just totally shattered 95
what can you find here oh wow 95 comes
in there's a pin og six
maybe you don't know is there rook takes
c6 no there isn't
there's I'm calculating ninety-seven
check and trying to find something 97 if
King f7 is Knight takes c6 and they
takes the 89 takes B said oh my gosh was
that used to be nasty getting a ton of
material for the Queen's
so 97
King g7 or King f8 and I don't see the
follow-up before for white there but one
simple follow-up is no I guess not
simple I I thought maybe you could take
he five and then take e6 but I forgot at
the end of that line the e7 Knight hangs
so I'm wrong boy but it does seem very
you're right it feels like blacks
position is hanging by a tactical thread
here he's hunting for four uh well do
you just trade the Queen's here and take
on okay no no no okay I mean worst case
he trades the Queen's he would place
nine P for a knight like he still
retains that sort of pressure against
against e7 but Magnus definitely wants
more this is the lowest he's gotten on
the clock in a long time that's good as
well like he's he's hunting for for win
yeah I mean that you can take you five
and play Knight f6 check almost but then
King of seven and he holds on he just
but now there's nine f7 I guess the
issue is you can just trade on d7 and
White's just like she just gets uh more
than he needs yeah yeah no this is this
is very often the simplest approach is
actually the right answer and that's
what Magnus finds well you see what
happened there you know a lot of us we
sense there's a win you spend a bunch of
time and we don't leave ourselves enough
time to convert when we actually at the
end we just panic and you play the five
seconds he has a minute twenty he's like
okay I spent a minute I couldn't find it
we'll go back to this other option which
is also quite safe and he just avoids
being in in serious time trouble like
with that very pragmatic approach thanks
to cat daddy moon who just subscribed on
Twitch thanks to all of our viewers both
on chest comm TV and twitch TV slash
chests all of our premium members at
chess comm we love you right after this
Eric you and I will will reflect on what
we just saw in fact right now the
players are gonna get up take their
break wesley knows he needs to do is
only a few minutes off you know he needs
to take that three minute break so let's
talk for a second here Eric about the
fact that well let me just ask you have
you seen the the new trailers from from
master class from Garry Kasparov the new
ones I don't think I have
the new one okay well we're gonna play
one of them right now okay Gary actually
revealing a little more about what he
has to offer master class of course one
of the big movers and shakers this year
having thrown together this course with
Gary Kasparov designed specifically for
serious tournament players or at least
aspiring to be really serious tournament
players let's tune into that real quick
during this break as Wesley so and
Magnus shake it off and get ready to
move into three two blitz
let's take a look at a special
behind-the-scenes look of what Gary
Kasparov has to offer some really
instructive endgame here and game traps
that everyone should know I'm here to
share with you my knowledge of the game
of chess it's not just checks and
attacks you have to be creative check
[Music]
and now we can look at few studies when
changing pieces could lead to a decided
advantage for one side or to be a
defensive mechanism to save the game
that looks otherwise desperate why does
an extra piece but our pool is under
attack and our might is under attack in
the middle game or in the opening you
definitely have to pay attention to this
threat because night is more valuable at
the pool but with an endgame
so protecting the night doesn't do us
any good if we protect the night and
black takes the pawn that's a surrender
control position rook and Knight cannot
win against alone but how can we benefit
from keeping this pawn alive a trick is
that we play a quiet move a three
doesn't seem logical black simply takes
the knight with the check but then King
- and surprise surprise the rook there
are so many moves cannot avoid the
exchange if rooks goes back on h1 or g1
the loop d1 will change rooks and our
palm is unstoppable but instead of
moving to the first rank
h1 or d1 like who can go back to a four
and then we understand why our poor
moved down to a four but to a three
sometimes very important you make just a
small move
one square but it has devastating effect
because this poem protects square before
and after hoop III check King goes on C
- or a - doesn't matter the loup-garou
before and rook black rook is trapped
technically is not trapped because like
an exchange rule either taking one
before and after a before alphorn is
unstoppable or moving crew kanji for and
then after exchange our pawn is again
stopped and that's one of the lessons of
this endgame super awesome stuff there
thank you - master class the supporting
sponsor of the 2017 speech Chess
Championship thank you to Grand Master
Eric Hanson for flying alongside me
today if you're just joining us you just
missed 90 minutes of chess dominance and
brilliance by the one and only the
Norwegian superhero and he might be a
superhero at least as far as chess is
concerned that is Magnus Carlsen Eric we
have an eight-point lead for the world
champion heading into three minute
give us your give us your fighters your
fighters speech right now Eric you got
Wesley so in the corner okay you're
you're his coach you don't have a choice
but to find a way to inspire and provide
motivation and to give some executable
advice go Eric what is Wesley need to do
Danny I would be the dirty coach trying
to grease up my fighter and I'm thinking
right now like you know I love you like
you like Wesley we can't win this match
put this on your glove well you know
remember what I said I said playing you
for he's done it okay actually is this
thing like I just just please mix up I
mean that's so so simple to say it's
really not enough but like I'll tell you
the punchline if you look Eric Hanson
won a few games in Vegas that means you
can as well you can win a lot more than
than I can so so that's just some simple
motivation you just do way better than
me because I I know that he is just
underperforming right now and it's just
just I don't know like these guys have
it tough like a psychological factor
against maintenance they play them all
I'm and have such difficulty getting
space or positions that that provide
winning chances and here are the in this
quick time control it's just compounds
yep but yes I would be I would be a
little idea putting grease on my fetter
and the time controls only get quicker
as Eric just said we are now in the
three minute portion less than an hour
it the clock tick tick tick away back 44
all right look at this Wesley's on the
on the Wesley on the hunt yeah I mean I
want to play you for I wanted to go for
open positions and I don't want him to
do that maneuvering stuff as much
anymore
Magnus is really sharp today with this
piece placement
you
sell me this position Bishop III work 81
go go go
looking good for white this is a good
position for white this is this is
already looking great
there should be three rock 81 he plays
it quickly we can even reroute maybe
bishop of two queen chief or Bishop h4
get on the dark squares up you mentioned
main as a superhero I guess what
superhero would you would it be his own
or like Clark Kent or something well I
mean okay the obvious choice is Thor
right the Norwegian thought god of
thunder
the lack of a man crush on Chris
Hemsworth who doesn't right I wouldn't
that would have a conflict of interest
my wife has a little more than a man
crush on Chris Hemsworth and and Ryan
Reynolds so maybe they make a list I
mean if it's a Canadian band it's only
obvious that yeah you know American
women you know do do like heating guys
well Magnus yeah I think the obvious
choice is Thor if he's his own if he's
his own superhero or I don't know where
I'd go with that I'd be on that but did
you see the new Thor we won't we won't
distract with that let's talk about this
week e6 pawn this is this is this is a
very very good position Wesley's up on
time that's the first time the match
I've seen mostly up on time besides me
I'm digging one all he needs to do gang
up on that a six pollen maybe place he
three at some point the only concern
about c3 is that Bishop money tree is
the problem but besides that you want to
play c3 focus on the e6 pawn and and
ride that I mean goes for it he wants
the e6 pawn now he's uh not interested
in waiting around I guess it's a nice
move because he's threatening Queens c4
here Erik and I think he might jump with
it
no Queen c4 threatened Queen C for a
play Queen f7 I really have a concern
here that this Bishop on a3 I'm going to
become an issue a cast away so he wants
to fix it now with d3 like yes that's a
great great approach here Queen e2 I
wouldn't be surprised to see but I think
Wesley can just ignore that and play
Bishop b2 okay King of seven he wanted
to avoid this I think also one of the
issues on Queen e2 is maybe Magnus or
maybe Wesley would have been able to
trade and played Bishop e2 with the
threat of rook d7 so maybe
okay yeah you're right I mean Magnus is
doing his best to get the second-ranked
as compensation for the pawn that he's
down but Wesley should be the only one
who can win this game now he should but
you know when you think about a pawn
event game you don't think about you
don't you know fantasize about double
death tonight is that not your thing
III don't I really don't this is this
would that wasn't an invitation to tell
us what you do fantasize it no and I
want to make sure it's not F pawns no
it's not it really white is on the
better side of this but it's all about
being able to maybe trade off on these
doubled pawns what for Magnus is you'd
bond like drinking this double bond so
you wouldn't play f5 it's gonna play
rookie for maybe he's drunk to it okay
f5 I thought maybe he had a five you
know what I'm really hard it's really
tough for me to evaluate these on the
fly like yeah what's the evaluation is
fine and being like intuitively it seems
like black is fine but then why would
Wesley rush into it when at least he's
on the better side of the engine yeah
right so it's like why why was he so
this is the best vision he's add and an
hour and he really rushed since that
pawn in game when we know if Magnus was
on the other side probably not uh-huh
and all of a sudden after the move King
III the evaluation bar just slid way
down in blacks favor by the way and I
don't I don't have an engine moves in
front of me all I have is that
evaluation bar that everyone else boxy
on the back yes because because what's
running out of moves oh this is this is
this is a new quest about lean back in
frustration there was no way he should
lose that game no no this is this is a
gonna make sure than how to recover from
this is incredible a player of Wesley's
well he's just he just out of it right
now he's just really struggling against
Magnus
his decision to trade into this pawn in
game so quickly was already an
indication you know something's a bit
bit off there that he was playing well
and I mean he's just now now he might
lose and now now now only black and win
and you know Magnus is not touching that
eight point he's gonna use these extra
couple tempos when when they're
necessary he seven to a six a six day
five but he was only playing reactive
chest Wesley was the one
I had with that extra pawn this is he
sort of provokes this is like king of
four yep it grabs opposition and this is
how you win a king upon ending everybody
if white goes the wrong direction
black will infiltrate wait he goes to g2
right it's gonna go for the edge five
pawns so we have the partners huh quick
calculation tells me that black is but I
could probably go for that but I guess
if you could also just well well the
problem is
yeah well thought can go for it with the
idea of queening the b-pawn picking up a
try to push the a pawn is it's gonna
region but now Magnus is just
calculating this out he's gonna clean
the beep on daddy yeah even if both
sides Queen his King is gonna be in the
right position to win the game so soon
as he wins a to everybody he's gonna
shoot a five and a four up the board and
this B pawn will be the one that gets a
queen and unless he has no he doesn't
have the time to do anything you can go
for the B part I think I did count that
right yep that's all bye please don't
embarrass me please don't embarrass us
Magnus Wow this is just this is just a
lot of pawns and and White has some
drawing chances here everybody because
the King's open and always a chance for
perpetual will check on a Queen upon
ending but it's clearly clearly I just I
feel like you know you're right it's
like the psychological hangover from
going down eight games after the
five-minute portion has got to have
Wesley feeling down because that's not a
that's not a normal Wesley so decision
back in that moment where he just traded
into the right back here everybody where
he just willingly trades into a King and
pawn ending you don't go for that if
you're the only one who can win a rook
ending unless you know you're the only
one who can win the king opponent and or
really it should be winning right Erik
but he goes for this it's just very
uncharacteristic of high-level Wesley so
chess to make that trade yeah okay and
there you have it whether he holds the
draw here or not which he might still
but it's just not a good sign for Wesley
hopefully if his sake he holds the draw
and rebounds but going down nine games
this early in the match would be would
be shocking I'm trying to figure out how
to get out of the checks and I don't see
a good way
so maybe this is a draw but again that's
all it's a victory for Carlson at this
stage of the match he's coming close to
clinching it Danny if you can maintain
this for the next 30 minutes yep yep
fans in the chat the twitch TV chat
sorry the twitch TV slash chess as well
as Jeff Scott Tom TV asking who Magnus
has in his room with him he's being
hosted I can tell you by a friend this
is not his home he told he told me that
in the pregame so somebody maybe was
over there cooking up a tasty dish
because now he's shoving food in his
mouth so if I had to guess all right
thank you anonymous just subscribed I
don't know if that's your username or
legitimately you found a way to be
listed as anonymous either way - che sir
all right game drawing by repetition we
move on
so back to the CARICOM caro-kann don't
tell the Carroll what it can't do
I don't know why I just said that but
this is this is a fun little line this
line with Bishop d3 in c3 we're gonna
get that structured that we've had a
couple times both with white and black
Eric right black is gonna play e6 here
which is gonna give us the pawn chain
that faces the Queen side versus
whatever white can mount using the
e-file as a springboard to the king side
this is a minority attack attack
structure with black having two pawns
versus White's three pawns on the Queen
side yeah this is this line is being in
fashion a bit more recently even crown
Nick is playing this is why it's so yeah
it was recommended to me a few years ago
by gingy as a line that had some bite
that people hadn't hadn't hadn't dough
been to properly enough but then right
around that time I became a terrible
chess player and stopped you in all
advice I was given Eric so alright but I
like White's position here and look at
that k1 d8 a pawn on d5 what happened
you put King did it very quickly trying
to figure out what just happened but I
would say when I'm seeing right now is
Wesley is you know at first it was like
Magnus was playing really well Leslie
still needed to improve a bit now I was
like Wesley's on tilt yeah he's out he's
actually like he's finding himself in a
in a lot of lost positions or just
terrible openings and the terrible
openings is the last thing you're gonna
see from Wesley Wesley so may get
outplayed and yet as you've said I think
I think a lot of people feel that maybe
even has too much respect for Magnus
obviously Magnus Magnusson can inspire
fear amongst his peers but this is still
this is just bad Oh interesting
look at that move everybody points out
that this bishop is poisoned on b5 if
you take it Magnus will take with the
knight take on d6 and Kruk crash through
on e5 eventually at the end of that line
so it's no surprise Knight f3 check
maybe no no
as long he just completely lost here now
so because even here if you he has this
fork right right but you've been even
even if you win that rook I really don't
like this position I'm expecting a move
like Bishop g3 but yeah this was his
idea
Magnus mister I missed that first but
the problem is that King on DA having
LightSquared Bishop I think is more
important than trying to retain some
other material yeah why should just play
up he's gonna a play before I could say
it bishop g3 have the knight on d6 and
yeah white already has a pawn for the
exchange here comes Knight b3 nice c5
yes 93 95 or cut them out on d4 that is
just you need to contest those dark
squares very quickly as as okay that's a
good move I mean that's the way you can
test the darks worse start by trying to
eliminate the bishop ooh but is there is
there Knight beef I thought there may be
93 96 g3 and Knight c5 Intermezzo Eric
but okay Magnus isn't interested in that
is that night on d6 trapped after Brooke
a6 or King e7 who he finds it I think
that night on on d6 has has wandered too
far from home yeah this is uh this is a
rounded position to blunder in but it
looks like he is actually hot so hard
it's a hard blunder - or hard easy
blender to make Magnus kind of shaking
his head there I think he's like oops
the knight is lost no he's blundered
that's just the Carlsen making a couple
buggers here still not game over we'll
see what happens yeah also you can see
Knight see for Brooke d1 as a chance to
keep it alive that's why Magnus is gonna
play maybe Brooke t4 and he has this
idea that after rook t4 rook t-there's
queen maybe Queen g5 check so I'm
expecting Rick d4 here he's gonna keep
this Queen g5 check in his pocket and I
have some ideas with that but I'm not
like yeah you're down a rook okay this
also works but yeah like you know this
was this was more of a case of Magnus
blundering but that's sometimes what you
need usually you can't count on it
let's see Wesley that was the bright
Brook to bring to d8 everybody yeah and
and it forces forces resignation by
Magnus which is a huge win there for
Wesley silver first win in like a dozen
games another anonymous user just
subscribed thank you for your support of
chess events and of twitch TV slash
chest so of K regardless of how we got
there and certainly Magnus turned what
was a brilliant opening with Wesley's
King on d8 right into a terrible middle
game but a wins a win and Wesley so has
stopped the bleeding officially he
stopped the bleeding he's gone back to
this Koli system I'm not exactly sure
why he had a very way at a good position
last game with p40 yeah let's see two
neuro tutor over Wesley that's really
around he gonna do - I feel like we're
talking to the Cleveland Indians here
back in the back in the movie
major-league if you win again
that's called two in a row if you win
three that's called a winning streak and
that's what we need to mount here yeah
okay this is a pretty standard position
all across the board
yeah and and black plays around this
then on e5
he puts the leaving down g6 sometimes he
gets a 94 whenever you got the chance
but you don't take on you five until the
time is right yeah there's some theory
here actually white Oprah hair for
either moves like 90th three to
reinforce the night or look for it you
can't really look for a chance to play
c4 anymore after I move like g3 because
you wouldn't really want to open up that
Bishop on b7 but maybe he is gonna go
for it yeah you may go you might go for
c4 honey I would I was highlighting it
likes
I don't like c4 for white yeah yeah open
up that Bishop on b7 and he agrees maybe
the rook on c1 was more just about
protecting this over protecting this c2
pawn against the glaring tower on CA but
after before I think we're gonna see
Knight be 395 by Westley 95 so who's
getting their first onion blocks gonna
have to contest that idea that is
probably a bit too much space to own and
see
and then me five so after after 93 you
might be able to play a night night with
94 these are always hard to evaluate but
I feel like this is a this is an edge
that's creeping with white and something
tells me that as well just in terms of
their time management you see Magnus
again falling behind on the clock and it
was done a couple times here in the
three minutes so well he is looking at
possibilities of sacrificing upon I'll
give you an example Bishop takes e5 de
594 you trade everything off you put a
rock on c4 and you try to like you know
give up all that reroute your Knight to
d5 your position you're down upon but
you have all the light squares and you
have a C file to work with before I just
highlighted your line there for the fans
I think they work C 497 a hearing
everyone Eric Eric you just predicted
another magnus carlsen approach although
Wesley says I don't like that in game
either and just it was a very practical
approach because it gives it the pawn
but then he gets the initiative so I
think this is a good rebound Wesley to
avoid it but that's obviously an
accomplishment for black if he's able to
just play 94 and get away with it Magnus
tilting over to his over to his right
into it seems to be a TV in the living
room there's some theories bouncing
around that he's watching the Real
Madrid match right now which is which he
we know he's a real Madrid fan Eric so
it's just a fun little fun little food
for thought I'm also a fan of Real
Madrid so no issues there yep all right
well here comes Knight to d2 for Wesley
I still yeah he plays it I like white to
get a second win in a row in this game
right now I feel like he's he's dealt
with this practical shot by Magnus with
94 well by kind of you know focus on it
strangling the C file he established
this Bishop on d4 so now when he does
eventually gobble up this efore night
Eric I think I think it's a much safer
edge for white now yeah I agree I know I
agree that he's handled very well he's
playing around he's not allowing Magnus
to get in those like exchange sacrifices
that make life so much easier and this
way he's doing it under
his uh his his way his way which is not
allowing this Bishop on b7 to become a
monster
Magus now Magnus now under a minute
takes e5 and finds a way to continue to
keep it practical which is what he does
so Bishop takes c4 and f3 Danny are you
I think he's just winning here Bishop
takes yeah even
oh there's Knight takes D 2 after f3 ok
but even just take e4 right and then
probably your take ticket form cleric
and trade everything off well Magnus is
gonna do this he's gonna put his Bishop
on d5 he's gonna put f5 in he's gonna
say you're up in exchange but I really
have a powerful Bishop on d5 and some
control so see big trunk card for White
will be the a and B pawns versus a
single a pawn so if white can again here
and Wesley knows that so he immediately
starts mobilizing his majority that's
what you have to do 6 bring the King to
d6 yeah both both sides have clear plans
the rooks need to get better they need
some open space open files we're gonna
generate that on Queen side black
obviously very strong the sound on the
board without confirmation but you'd
like to play around
now b6 is the movie you'd like to play
as white here and play would be 5
yeah and he's gone for it I think you're
right that it even if you end up losing
that be pawn you don't want to let black
get the King to d6 and fully fully uh
come together
shoutout to bend over who just
subscribed on our twitch channel
[Music]
yeah Brooke to b5 looks like it's coming
and I think Magnus is thinking cuz he
he's not sure he could hold the same
game anymore which again would would be
two in a row for the American and the
the massive underdog watch over here's
don't go for the c4 pawn cuz it's your
you know the King on you two there's
some pins you might have to walk it I'm
not convinced actually like this a pawn
is really hard to push for I can block
again this trade of the a for the B part
he's gonna play with b3 he's gonna play
a brick b2 of King b4 and he's gonna put
the Bishop on d5 and usually when you
see people like lose these positions
it's often the rooks are like connected
and working together I don't see that
yet I see the bishop in the rook working
better than the two books as right now
right there there the rook on d1 really
needs to find an active role it doesn't
have that yeah this is the opposite of
active going to f1 but I think this
might still be the right plan for Wesley
to say all right obviously if I can get
me a pawn up that might that might give
me what I need but but you need the rook
behind the poem because official in
default controls a a and and we're
almost going to be the situation here so
he's going for rook takes c3 rook a1 he
looked behind the pawn but we're almost
in situation Dani where black will
gladly sacrifice the bishop for the a
pawn and has a whole bunch of conscience
right yep yep so that's what he's aiming
for but Magnus is really low on time
here so Wesley is still pushing and
doing well here the stock goes up very
nice move this move rook d7 bulwark d3
is fantastic because it you can just
take with the bishop and the D pawns
this is some cold blooded chest by
Magnus I mean in terms of producing
counter play this is pretty remarkable
Brooke c1 is what I might have to play
here rook c1 yeah I don't think you can
allow it with you one this is he's
opposing a lot of issues yeah rook c1
seemed forced rook check and if the King
moves there is still a threat of rook
takes d5 can remove this Bishop every
but there is 65 is the threat it's funny
both sides have threats here because if
Magnus can trade the C pawn for the a
pawn block is gonna be better than again
probably with the bishop
coupons listen it's the rook back but if
a move for move like rook takes
I wondered if okay you couldn't get away
with rook take c2 because not enough
time in a line like this but Magnus
really getting one time you're he's
trying to play a foreign King e5 he's
what he's gonna do is he's ready
sacrifice that rook for that a pawn but
claim that he has enough pawns down the
board that the rook oh that's that might
be that might take on c7 and play III
Danny and run my king to four
I'm not sure who's ahead here because if
if blacks King gets to f3 and he's
winning because I mean okay later all we
miss Roxy five no no II - Queen - isn't
it with check no cuz I have a skewer on
I ate at the end very nice so rook c5 b
- queen and that's a blunder
yeah Magnus that is a blunder by Magnus
cakes Queen excellent excellent
excellent find daddy that a queen here
and you got the Queen to EA check all
that miss isn't giving up he's gonna
trim work the e pawn forward but his
that's a that's a ended look at that
match is getting closer that one games
two games in a row that was a very
exciting game overall yeah back and
forth that was really good
that was uh I mean and whether he's
watching Real Madrid or not Magnus might
need to focus a little more on what's
going on here on the three-minute
portion and got to go back to our stats
obviously as what we predicted based a
lot of this is just based on now well
not just what we know about these
players and their their their careers
against each other but also what we've
measured by how they played in certain
time controls both in this in these
matches on chests chimeric and outside
of these matches we're really putting a
lot of work into trying to predict
accurately and see if we can create kind
of a module that would be so I mean I
think we all predicted Wesley so would
do better in the 3-2 portion and right
now he's doing just that
yeah I I'm the one who didn't predict
that but he is doing better
and that is that is good for the mash
situation because at one point couple
games back man this was really close to
just almost as I mentioned clinching it
now now it's now there's enough time
he's won two games in a row we don't
know how much more you can build on that
but Magnus is also susceptible to you
know emotions and yam and getting
frustrated so we have to see how he
deals with this new new pace where
Wesley's been quicker and he's actually
uh scored a couple wins
Magnus seems to have recovered a little
bit here though I mean this is uh I
don't know my first instinct is what
happened to blacks pawns on the light
squares but maybe maybe black is more so
we're seeing a lot of King news in the
openings we sing a lot like well not
castling and like I'm concerned maybe
not concerned but I have a feeling we're
gonna see a lot of players watch this
match and start putting their King on e2
in K on d1 I'm just chilling there and
say oh you know I saw Magnus do it I saw
Wesley do it masters of this every this
level everybody you do as they say not
as they do because there's some funny
stuff we're gonna see people emulate
this I feel like White has to be close
to figuring away at the black King can I
just borrow a 7-point by the way and
even if you don't you have the you know
a half-open age file you got a bishop
being stacked in an open position he's
got a few different attractive options
and taking on b7 he'll do that if he
thinks that limits all blacks
counterplay but maybe even like some
sort of Knight takes e5 line cuz that
pawn is pinned oh wow look at this move
he doesn't even care about the d4 pawn
he's headed for f7 with devious
intentions maybe now he'll have to
settle on a trade or though Bishop f7
how do you stop mate coming to e6
Bishop f7 I guess you guess you can take
C 5 and if rook takes then you can play
Brooke takes f7 yeah yeah yeah sweet
razor fade this is a sharp game these
guys are gonna have to take some more
time than normal
start to calculate this out there's some
calculation required here yeah like I
take Sofia Queen takes f8 can you take
on b7 a lot of considerations I
generally just will favor white it is
you know I didn't appreciate open
position
yeah Knight takes e5 here Knight takes
e5 here and d4 saying after Knight takes
e5 expect Queen to e3 so that's probably
why he didn't take the pawn it looks
very attractive but and it does win upon
but white does have that Queen e3 move
here yes maybe the right practical
decision right just to not open this a3
f8 Dagon with a king that's why he
doesn't go for this e5 pawn but if he
can you know start in Queen d4 and he's
attacking the bishop on so yeah so I'm
thinking if White has to place is a
great point c3 then black is doing fine
again no yeah I want to keep that Bishop
please that Castle Danny that seems like
always Kings on the only way to keep the
bishop my position should be 5 and that
would actually block the Queen from
hitting the d4 pawn and simultaneously
unpinned upon so maybe that's his best
chance
oops no Queen settles on Queen c3 he's
gonna let the bishop be traded okay but
if you're Wesley you you didn't get
mated with your King on e7 so what's
this flank energetically this game
you're getting a vibe here like yeah
some precise moves he's playing quicker
yep he's got his mojo back Eric knows
how to read vibes as well as anybody in
the room so I'm gonna go with I'm gonna
go with Eric's yeah he's a confident guy
his King in there yeah this King the
center um King III speaking of king of
the eye he played it I called it yeah
you didn't call it and if the Queen's
were off the board this would be a
dominant endgame for white because of
the king positioning yep if you can keep
that King on you three I'd really do
like White's prospects I make tools
thank you for subscribing it gives it
gives a little check there and might be
time for the Queen and King to play a
little pickle tickle here King III queen
chief oh yeah if you're white though
your mom what you may want more than the
tickle but you
can't really protect you from you play
d5 up like Whitney five and I'm winning
in pawn anyways what if we give up the
d4 pawn and try to flip into c7 somehow
like Queen B so I can rook c7 or I don't
know right right
almost reminded me the first game of the
match Romanies is down upon me as his
plane he needs the king
so Queenie five I expect the Queen
before check is what I'm thinking and he
wants some sort of rook c6 or queen c6
he's gonna take aged six would check got
you right unless he's gonna get made it
on the dream file
I guess he decided he didn't want to get
made it on the deep or you know he goes
back to your point that even with the
loss of that D pawn white is on the only
one who can win this reckoning cuz that
King is coming up so much faster than
blacks King that's right
that is right it's an even material
endgame but the King position is is
pretty significant here that if rook e5
just king III okay so he's up the pawn
and he what's nice about this position
is in a lot of cases you can really
indulge your pawns f3 at the right time
will provoke black to trade on f3 and
impact and white structures fixed so
it's patched up so this is Magnus needs
to play a bit quicker but he's
consolidated here I believe and yeah
this is gonna be a tough hold this is
critical a draw block is a great result
for Wesley he's won two games in a row
he's kept the pawns doubled but yeah
this King position might tell tell a
story again okay so Rick have 200
fortune yeah yeah okay well those are
there's an extra two pawns but they are
doubled will called I don't know 1.25
let's say well thank you had some random
oh all means is black needs to keep the
rooks on the board you cannot cannot
trade here but otherwise that's what
you're right though a hold here would be
a huge result for Wesley
drawing his black is never a bad thing
against Magnus Carlsen and
if you've won two in a row you don't
want to let Magnus get back to a vintage
Magnus win and grind you down and what
is probably a draw and ending but but
hard to hold against Magnus see the
feature of having double pawns instead
of single parties you can actually trade
rooks by Rajesh that's a big advantage
and I'm struggling to see how to deal
with that right now the point everybody
Eric is highlighting is even a move like
B takes a four would be good here
because rook f5 check takes takes and
takes takes and takes and White's just
gonna win this King and pawn ending
because I have the F oh he goes for it
he's just losing you just missed this
well well I'm thinking that the amount
of time oh he can sack the a pawn right
I sleep carbon - very nice so what he's
gonna do everybody is is Wesley's gonna
gonna bait White's King - getting
further up the board as you see in at
some point he's gonna sacrifice this a
pawn just as he did and Magnus won't be
able to win he'll win the pawn the
blacks King will reach a or lets it be
in in time yeah and it's gonna have well
played very well played you know they're
gonna dance quite a bit here but at some
point White's King has to make the
decision I steal me my opponent on g8 or
I bring my king over pick up the a4 pawn
but then the time it takes for that
block is gonna be line down the 8th and
reach be a where a any of the drawing
squares so he's really understood that
yep
the King dance yeah B it's the square
yeah there we go
well played super well played in a big
victory for Wesley so to get that draw
he's bounce back bounce back in the
three minute portion hasn't lost yet in
three minute portion if you're keeping
track at home and he's gone back
confidently to his weird you know
ready dims Oh Larsson dealio here
alright but Magnus Magnus get a sharp
game here it's gonna be hanging pawns
white tries to play e3
or well maybe d3 first but at some point
he's gonna play for d4 although actually
I think I've had this position against
the Astor a few times he likes to try to
like try to trade off that knight on c6
and play a 45 and just hit this pressure
on this b6 bomb with without giving
black any space that's the benefit of
those English formation he do e to the C
forests are no breaks against it without
a deep on it's very hard to achieve e5
so yeah he's gonna go for a 45 I've lost
it to be entirely like this yeah sirs in
English so yeah you get these positions
worth the b-pawn is weak the Queen can
come from the c2 to be to where she both
hits b6 battery facing toward the Kings
side and white is white is comfortably
in control this is a tough diagonal
situation for black because the c-4 d3
e2 structure really just kind of holds
the e4 square holds the d5 square and it
keeps blacks pieces out of the center
right it's a tough tough situation for
black this is right because black needs
to play Bishop f6 and try to simplify
trading off you can you can simplify
it's gonna be a nagging edge for white
that's and that's the first time in a
while well not in a while but Wesley
from this opening he's getting and
getting something I think tangible I
think you take on b6 you play like Queen
B 2 or rugby 1 here but like you're the
only one who has a target and I think
that's that's a great position being in
blood time in this match circumstance
where he is slowly but surely finding
his form yep agreed town we are there he
is it's like because what does what
commands do here he asked to sit back in
the Wesley dictate the pace right and
that's not where he's uh comfortable
yeah white can play even moves like f3
94 play moves like you just see Brooke
83 now he's gonna prepare to double on
the B file and or the a file I guess
he's still like you said he kind of
dictates the terms of surrender his rook
a seven really good cuz Queen T 694
magnets just blundered a piece did
oh and oh I forgot even 47 because of
yeah okay my dad either way like whites
just taking bottles because it got this
b6 fun if you try to get rid of it by
Bundy 510 c5 becomes a week so it's
really just white is going to oh well
Leslie just that was surprising
I actually am surprised I look like I've
I've lost a few games like that way
maybe I missed it I but I I I like that
you just have the a file you have your
weaknesses and you can push I that'll
definitely be a girl my Marty just made
a mental note to ask Wesley about that
game in the post game in in the post
match interview because I wonder if his
the feeling was I mean okay he's clearly
gained some momentum he's on a roll why
not try to grind out and push for a win
one theory eric is maybe he thinks
Magnus would hold after a really long
game and he wants more chances to strike
and get a darker position so yeah I'm
gonna make a note of that will ask
Wesley if that was a match strategy draw
so they are repeating a position when
Magnus had a beautiful attack via the
edge file in the 5-2 portion
I can hear you writing no that's right
so I know I don't use paper often but
when I do it's because I'm making those
purchasing me well regardless of the
momentum shifting back to the America
and obviously magnus carlsen still holds
a six-game leading the match and he's
back back to his old tricks here and the
kind of position we expect if we're
looking for a slow grind usually magnus
carlsen is controlling the tempo of that
grind thank you to Tim I couldn't even
read your username my Kido Reese 5/5 for
subscribing to our channel appreciate
the love and and that's a pawn on d5 yes
that that would be quite unfortunate for
Wesley to lose some of this momentum
without blender the problem is after GT
White's gonna play King g2 in challenge
the H file so it's not even like a
sacrifice for like this age without
compensation yeah it's it's just King G
to enrich your catch one this is this is
a Magnus I think can sense this is a
clear moment where if he wants to kill
that momentum this is it maybe Queen g4
followed by Knight e4 Queen g4 and
lightly or I don't know something like
that although black is gonna double
image file I might not be waiting that
night but Queen it looks like I am like
I just simply I play rook a 94 okay okay
good good good so far following it but
905 like like how do you win this net on
on on h3 well you can try to play Knight
h4 but it Department is it's hard
there's nine at five now did you play
rook h1 you literally have to play Ricky
- on Ricky - Ricky - h1 to win it yeah
Magnus is gonna take a thing to probably
calculate lines that Eric is talking
about because as Eric said after Knight
age 4 Knight f5 there's just a lot of
tactics coming on the h-file so you
can't just safely grab that night yeah
he is in control because he's not
committed to winged then he just wants
to and it's very tempting like right guy
can't get over the net on h3 that's what
you feel when somebody does that right
uh because otherwise he's up upon it
he's not facing any serious threat
when I just want me to take h3 first
Eric and then nine h4 I guess you let
him give the rook back but you would be
convinced rook back yeah I'm gonna each
file there might be this f4 square yeah
this might not be fun looks really
tricky because the block is committed to
keeping that night whereas white hasn't
committed to trapping his pieces can
still do other functions so I actually
think this is a really nice approach by
Magnus f7 is now hit I know this this is
this is really smooth this G pipe on
can't be taken because if Knight takes
rook takes rook takes H ADA's lights out
so Magnus pointing out that there's a
pin on this h-file okay so this looks
like a desperate attempt but it may
actually work I mean the g6 pawns gonna
fall and the question is well looks like
everything is falling
I mean maybe or maybe just take f6
actually seems safer just gobble f6
instead no okay Magnus wants g6
yes his design here's all the options
here there's not a threat for black
where it takes you okay terrific g6 is
the threat cuz where's Nana for check so
don't allow it overtakes tree six here
that's all yep all I can say besides now
you can move the night away you can play
9 f8 you can shout out to smoking a big
pot for this for the sub yeah Eric is
highlighting something like this if you
can't go for this and and and blunder
your queen an image for black can apply
was night each to f4 check and still be
annoying so Magnus took on on g6 now he
is like okay so gonna have six tactics
[Music]
he's really saying though that black has
nothing like he can just like h-file
stack is is nothing is that that's just
a blunder look at five yes except to
yeah oh wow Magnus and you know it's
annoying about Rick at five is after
Queen FIV f5 is also Queen c6 check so
you don't have time to play rook takes
there's Queen c6 check that was a
blunder but it's still as such wonders
many seven is a big time
move there though cuz you stopped 26
check and you must threaten I think I
was gonna say Queen d7 probably does the
trick though cuz I don't know after nice
eaking v8 everybody blacken like an even
play moves like Knight f4 checking her
MS o followed by Queen g7 Chuck and rook
g g8 eric is met by Queen to d5 lights
out yeah it's interesting like we're
seeing some some blunders by Magnus
little uncharacteristic and this game
moves from a position of strength I'll
say that's more uncharacteristic you
know is the best for sure I think
everybody including Magnus Carlsen makes
blunders when they're in bad positions
and they've been outplayed because
that's human nature
yeah but blundering when you're winning
that is something Magnus Carlsen does
like three times a year so check one of
them off the list
it's just that was trouble as well
Andy's in temperature I agree so this is
this is this is an interesting thing and
again it not to talk about how do we
deal with this position right now like I
actually 96 is being threatened Magnus
this might be winning for black buddy
ice has to find it with a minute on the
I still like the night of forecheck idea
you can't take it because I can kind of
flip the script between g7 you have
three and you go for it the nice thing
is when the King moves I can bring the
knight back to e6 and disconnect the
rooks from communicating that nice
that's that's the solution well played
that is that should be what's winning I
don't see anything to stop that yeah
yeah stone yeah and now we've got Queen
d5 check coming as well so probably
Magnus will throw in the towel here with
22 seconds on the clock but this is this
is this is a momentum shift right now I
mean if you're looking at the scoreboard
everybody only 17 minutes left but after
this win by Wesley Queen b5 check
mm-hmm after this one Wesley yeah is
that like a 3-0 run yes I mean with a
couple draws sprinkle with a couple
draws that's what I mean in terms of
like +3 he
it was it was +8 or something at some
point now we're looking at +5 I think it
was 11 to 3 at the maximum so this is
this is not something we see ya there
that's with Magnus thanks to our last
three subs quake [ __ ] need dumbs Danny or
something and some thanks and thanks
everybody who's supporting the channel
and tuning in to the show right now
appreciate the love and guess what we
have a match ladies and gentlemen with a
with a big swing here in the 3d portion
people that are surprised Wesley so just
his result last week that comeback was
incredible so can't be questioning his
resilience when he he put together when
the biggest comebacks ya ever in a blitz
chess match between two top players no
and that was and it was it was shocking
I think what's the momentum about going
in Wesley sauce direction dimming his
Ferraz didn't quite know what to do with
himself and we're not used to that from
Wesley that's showing some some
improvements I would say he's you know
challenging some of the critics despite
losing three games in a row
Magnus thinks that something is
hilarious with whoever he's hanging out
with maybe Wesley appreciates whatever
they can do to distract Magnus says he's
clearly looking at the real madrid game
I think I'm pretty sure now if we did a
if we did a zoom in on his glasses he
must be watching soccer while while
playing this match here but but he may
not be laughing for very long if Wesley
the stone-cold face there and what looks
like a pantry or a kitchen if Wesley
gets another win that this could be what
would that be it would pull it within
four games and if you're Wesley you just
got to be happy that the thing is within
striking distance after you fell buying
behind by nine full games it was nine
right or was it eight I think it was
nine eleven to three games I thought it
was twelve to three one but I could be
wrong you're right maybe maybe it was
eleven three was the maximum alright
well Wesley's playing quick I'm not sure
how much Magnus has picked up on that
because it doesn't look like he's
adjusted his pace yeah he is very
relaxed that's something like yeah you
have to point out he's laughing he's
relaxed yep you don't see you just
see that everyday not many people can
afford to be that relaxed but he's gonna
be worse here I mean Rusty's gonna take
back on b2 and blacks gonna be strapped
with by the way tonight that was a very
cute little trick there Eric if black
takes with the night he can can he take
on c6 and play b4 what was the reason
Magnus doesn't take with the night there
oh you take some c6 he plays night I 94
yeah y'all show that c6 v6 be for move
yeah that would have been real nice and
instructive tactic to show the fans if
night takes we would have had shots Oh
guys who thinks Wesley's gonna gonna
make a comeback here this is the time
this is the time to jump on the betting
line yep you got some good odds you got
some good odds and you're taking
advantage of the momentum obviously our
predictions still say Magnus Carlsen as
the heavy favorite for a good reason but
this is why it's a game and not a
science or maybe this is this is why the
game is played isn't that some
ridiculous football cliche this is why
they play the game the Bears were who we
thought they were Magnus Carlsen was who
we thought he was and he's getting
outplayed here though white still being
trade off it's gonna be hard to I mean
he's got his pawn like jambe 387 both of
sort of weak maybe a bit of an edge
towards white because the Knights might
be a little little unsafe but yeah I
don't see much it seems he's pretty dry
but again I think Wesley is the type of
player we look at as a great results as
great performances they were often draw
draw draw win drought he would just
never lose
vintage Wesley he's not making blunders
he's drawing some whenever he feels
uncomfortable but then he's put
sprinkling a win here there and that's
how he won a few super tournaments just
like a very steady you know tournament
cross-table like Ravi I'll win him and
he's doing that right now as long as he
avoids losses this is how
this has always had a lot of success so
now you tube runs into King h19 takes
you one mean takes d2 and then the
knight is trapped okay but but but I
shouldn't like maybe black can play rook
d8 here rook the air runs into the 84 ah
very nice
I shouldn't say it runs into it because
it still might be oh okay yeah but it
can be six there but it's yeah it's a
bit of a mess rook d5 don't be surprised
if Magnus has fantasies of a famous mate
something like rook h5 and after the
knight gets attacked rook takes h2 and
Queen h4 mate that is known as I believe
honest Aziz maid I walk official thanks
for subscribing yeah I don't I don't
remember the names of all my checkmates
I just know the favorite positions I
like and that was a good one
I should use I don't remember names very
well or openings right so I should
definitely do of your favorite positions
yeah doctor to write that down for my
tinder
all right rookie - yeah Wesley wait no
there is the combo here Queen takes F -
you just missed it
Oh highlight of a moment we dicks F -
that's right just blur it rook C - Queen
takes F - if white takes at rookie one
was matin bake everybody oh oh oh
Magnus cracking up Wesley that is if
someone doesn't clip that moment and
help that thing go viral there's nothing
more I can do for you all of our fans
here please clip the last 45 seconds 30
seconds of that game because that was
bananas
Eric sorry that was that was just it was
crazy
no we did not expect Wesley in that form
falling for some of these motifs that
we've all seen quite a bit but you do
you know 100 games fall for and that yes
that one and that is unfortunately he's
on the wrong side of a highlight reel
there yeah Queen takes f2 and the 93
Brook
eh five is it you and I you and I love
when our when our inappropriate
directions of the conversation become
relevant because in that situation
Wesley did not have one of his favorite
positions and it ended up being a puzzle
book mate I mean that was seriously
Queen takes up to 93 somebody put it in
tactics trainer that is going to be in
dr. Turner
all right well Wesley Wesley's gotta
shake it off you said bench's Wesley's
is wins and draws and that was that was
the kind of game you don't want to have
happen but that's why it's blitz you
know it was the kind of game at least
you're in West issues right now before
your were like how do I beat Magnus how
do I do now
that loss you attribute to yourself i
blundered maybe I was getting a little
too yeah you know optimistic but at
least that's in his control when the
real till happens when you're like how
do I be Magnus Carlsen like the guy just
gives me no room right now yeah it's in
his control if he takes it the right way
I think you can recover here appreciate
he's got a great position white phoenix
and love chess for subscribing
appreciate it
alright well now now we're back to
something a little more tame a little
less well this is gonna be this is
actually very it is team but it's very
very important in this specific position
that black plays f5 for because
otherwise his five pawns on the kingside
are sort of useless to him you know
they're very hard to push to sort of
block his ambition why it would be
playing c-4 93 95 and taking over
playing around yeah that formation the
only reason this formation could be good
is in the middle game with an attack so
Wesley has to attack this game and I'm
expecting fireworks I'm expecting up for
me so I think Dean's on the board
because the endgame is not being good
those double pawns are just White's just
gonna leave them there and say I have
inside majority yep yeah fantastic
educational points there by Eric black
needs to be all in here because the
structure greatly favors white if we had
to an endgame so Magnus is gonna try to
put the kibosh on that with g3 to over
protect f4 but you don't f4 is gonna
come anyway it doesn't matter what you
do to stop at four because as you said
Eric he doesn't really have a choice in
hearing he's going before that's good
now I like it though at least that I
think
was the right read of this position and
his bishop is going to see a and going
to some money squares
f3g for all-inclusive maybe you throw in
a move like King aged seven here you
want to be real prophylactic just
avoiding any pins and getting off the
back rink other okay so night see one
got to be nice you won the night
strapped so you're down to pawns but you
got the protect I'm not sure would have
done that but if you're gonna do that
you're really banking on me because
you've just closed off your books
you're really banking on the fact that
you can maybe play Queens you for all
wreckage five followed by work age five
sorry Brooke f5 hollow metal cage five
all those lights great ideas he's really
banking on on me here before at least he
could open up that file no it's no it's
all that what yeah I can do don't like
the medium or patient approach they're
from black but it you know it's
definitely all in right White has
everything that you would ever need to
win a game over here on the queenside
and so maybe whether Magnus can defend
the mating net gets the Queen on f1 look
I'm gonna put my bishop on c8 and trying
to play Bishop h3 Bishop g2 and do some
sort of queen sac what's he doing here
interesting but should obey should a six
he wants to stop the Queen from getting
the a6 I would play queen f1 now and a
bishop a6 I would place c4 followed by
b3 and at least let me guess the f1 oh
this is this is a critical game here the
players are going for it
rook rook g6 start include dick search
for the Jeep on his pins queen a king h2
might be a solution here although then
then maybe Bishop see a queen in g4 is
an idea Orochi 406 h4 this is this is
serious Magnus does need to do something
urgent actually I don't think he can
maintain this route takes g3f to check
is also in the air this is this is very
dangerous Vegas hosta has to sacrifice
factor it out pieces but I'm starting to
think that what is his position yeah
yeah he goes king h2 but now it's her
people but real quickly if Queen f1
Bishop CA and I want to do rook takes h4
gh4 Queen h4
bring mother
they'll ever check me on the G file so
Bishop queen queen f1 bishop see it I
think is a move that he may have
underestimated Bishop c8 Bishop see here
and rook take stage four and then you
bring the other to the G file problem is
this net under c1 what is it doing
nothing wrong so couldn't cut an apple I
could even play g5 here black has time
to do right to pry open okay he goes for
Bishop c8 as you said this is this is
yeah and now and now whoo here he goes
he found the combination it is 84 it's
over the kingdom account run to f1 daddy
because there is business
Bishop a6 and now you keep the pin wait
a second now he needs they don't even
need to do a play Brooke d8 even right
yeah really gives up on him and he finds
it Wow
no this was it now he could take with
the bishop and take with the bishop and
just go at the endgame yeah because the
king is still stuck well again we
already know we've been highlighting
that Wesley so has persevered very
recently very impressive so he lost he
lost a crazy game that was highlight a
bull about five minutes ago and guess
what
well he just he just returned the favor
now Magnus talk about how doc converts
this okay because it still needs that
little push do you try to play Queen to
c2 do you try to put your new queen d3
check once rookie six maybe
Queenie three Brooke d6 and flip back to
the Kings side I kind of like that Queen
d3 check King g1 rook d6
I'll play King h2 maybe of Queen e2 okay
that seems like it's winning
he needs to yeah that's no you're right
I guess I was jumping the gun the
highlight reel isn't fully submitted yet
because if Wesley doesn't convert this
properly Magnus might wiggle his way
into a draw no here's an alternative or
maybe he plays like rook F a rook out
for haha or here it gets his Queen d2
should be winning he just needs to watch
out for perpetual so Queens you for
there's I don't even though there's no
perpetual here yeah this is this is uh
this is gonna be we're gonna see a
resignation fairly how can we take some
coming with main structure wanted me
taken what you do after what you won
he's what made us is saying is I wrote
extra seven with a perpetual no way
Wesley just blundered into the perpetual
oh my gosh but but what that was like
really I mean I had to take time there
that's ridiculous from West I said no no
I mean that was too too too simple
that's like no I was you know I mean
play play look D seven instead of D one
Queen and it's one of those oh man that
is heartbreaking for Wesley guy and I
mean that's the sort of thing that
that's the sort of thing when I do throw
my chair or break something like a mouse
that is like you know exactly you you
know these are the best players in the
world I converting they know exactly
when somebody's like up to like a swing
by check or swindle yeah yeah that was
telegraphed too much no I mean the
position was you know plus six fur for
Wesley so Magnus any chance was rook
takes sheet seven but yeah like I am
shocked that he fell for that I really
am oh my gosh yeah well heartbreaking
therefore Wesley certainly uh the match
isn't over yet even the only thing I can
say is he maybe had the adrenaline
dumped where he played such a good game
you already thought he was winning and
you just lose all sense of objectivity
there but like that's not character
that's not Wesley so doesn't fall for
those he's like out of all the players
he's like I'd say he's less likely to
fall for that than Magnussen's like like
he's just he's a machine
Wow yeah Wow well the the perpetual was
just click clipped by her buddy King
wiki so thanks for that but I thought we
had a highlight the other direction from
a brilliant attack by Wesley so honestly
in that last game just spoiled and the
problem is right now the reason you can
see Wesley looking over his left and
right shoulder from time to time is
because here
still beating himself up about it and we
talk about that in this format Eric it's
it's you know there's not there's no
there's no rest day there's no time to
recover when you make a really silly
mistake like that and but you have to
find a way to let go of your emotional
baggage quickly but it's tough to do
when you've just blown I mean honestly
the position was resigned before Magnus
and you allow the one swindle for a draw
so ya know it's uh I'm actually not sure
what's worth sometimes when you're
frustrated with yourself that's when I I
can sometimes yeah tilt tilt much worse
yeah because you've just trained for too
many hours of your life into chest yeah
you when you were like you know you can
see that was a that was not a deep
breath of frustration about the position
he currently has everybody that was a
that was again that was him leaning back
and still struggling to forget the
previously I'm totally understandable
this is the struggle this is I'm really
curious to see how I I did not recover
that that's one of my weaknesses is I
really have an issue well when I fall
for those things yeah against the guy I
need to pick up a winning it's well this
position by the way this position by the
way I'm trying to evaluate this I'd say
it's like about equal but I kind of like
the position for black somehow I feel
like you take on c4 he took with a
knight if you look at the pot I put my
Knight to d7 to c5 I I guess no usually
Queen I give you these positions you
favor the outside passport if I think
you will be are this will be our last
game of the three minute segments
everybody and we will be moving on to
chess960 and then bullet it is on like
Donkey Kong you know what happens in
bullet chest so alright Magnus is gonna
just take the draw here and we're gonna
head immediately to chess960 but yeah I
mean you're still I think we're all
still shaking our head like Wesley just
there because of the the last let's get
look at this this looks a slow zone yeah
sorry keeper that was chess960 the rooks
were on the rooks
the Brooks were on the wrong squares I
think the players are bored of the game
because they thought it was a real game
look at that but that was a chess960
position the brook was on the road the
brook was on the night square did you
see what I'm talking about right yeah
very weird very weird yeah
these players know the match format and
I think they both thought that they had
had a classical game started there
instead of a normal game and aborted but
that was indeed a chess960 position so
very strange but this is a weirder
chess960 position and what do we have
here well we're getting a Marathi
structure again Danny yeah we got this
one on c4 unless he's got e6 so this
could actually turn into a very normal
for this Bishop to head to the h1 a a
diagonal and for white you just Castle
long I think we're gonna see Bishop f3
and then Magnus is gonna drop the King
on a1 which will complete the castles
long in the chess960 and I think I think
White's got the edge here in the middle
game well likewise a in these passes no
this is this is the trans 960 was the
portion where it's a bit of a wild card
and I feel like yeah you know I try to
try to change the momentum against
Magnus there but he's he's not been
getting into he's been getting into bad
positions that have a resemblance to
like normal chess positions yeah
which gives Magnus just another chance
to sort of maintain his his comfortable
lead in the match which is at six games
right now I have to say though the game
Wesley played before he bought it I was
oh that was a really really really well
played a well executed attack and it's
it's like it's one of those games if he
had won he even knows that's gonna be
like featured like that's a beautiful
game where you stack a piece and all
these pawns and win and just the
reversal is just heartbreaking
it's like you're going for this you know
slam dunk miss it at the rim but it is
yellow instead of doing a layup well
okay so in this position I expect both
players to play King be a king be one
yeah and now it's a matter black needs
to challenge the e-file that's too much
to give up again after you might be
hanging challenged the e-file so you do
want to bring that bishop off of yi8 at
some point it's hard to do hard to
execute and that's why this is just very
uncomfortable for it's uncomfortable for
black because Bishop d7 allows Ricky 7
there's a pin on on now and I have six
he really lacked space here but if
there's no actual threat then I guess he
can he can manage Queen b6 and he's like
okay for my troubles at least I have a
pawn there's a couple variations here
I'm looking at maybe Bishop takes f6 and
94 and trying to take on f6 and just
clean the better structure although I
don't like giving up the bishop pair
especially because d6 is a weak poem for
block of the Benoni pawn and I would
rather keep my Bishop dr. Bishop that's
white and attack that but it's hard to
come up with with a move here for white
that it increases the edge and he is
down a fall I don't think that's that
what's in trouble I think it's sort of
balanced but so yeah this is the
chess960 game that are headed to bullet
Wesley is is playing better though
playing better showing some very good
stabbing out here yeah he did much
better in the into 3-2 portion but job
but yeah we will we're getting close to
situations where yeah like his his draw
draw win thing he's gonna have to put
together more more wins to get within
striking range I think I think maybe
like you got a shrink this lead from six
games 3 to realistically believe as a
player that that you can catch up to
this match six games you know it's hard
to read you know really think yeah like
I can make up six teams at three games
get a couple quick ones in yeah I got a
chance I'm gonna go for it so let's see
here he did take on f6 he does have the
better structure we got opposite bishops
but Wesley it's a very comfortable
position I am seeing if I'm playing
black here that White's King I think is
a bit bit worse I'm gonna play a five is
black I'm gonna constantly threaten
things on the king's head like a five a
four or something I really like to do
here and put some nagging pressure like
by threatening moves like Queen b3 check
at the right time I also love to get my
Bishop on e5 that is the dream square
there's any way to reroute that Bishop
there but worst case situation play rook
d7 here although rook d7 might run into
Bishop e2 47 Bishop e2 we need four okay
that doesn't quite work so West needs to
figure out the right configuration
because right now he's actually just
bleeding pawns and yeah in fact it's
it's looking looking rougher by the
second even just trading to the endgame
with Queen b3 probably only white can
win yep Magnus goes for it
so which pond do you take okay takes the
F pawn goes rook h7 okay this is gonna
be a this should be a draw it's it's
very hard to convert this as white
because a d5 pawn blocks from Bishop
blacks Bishop e5 to the inker did very
nicely and can really harass the pawns
so even if you win h7 the problem is d5
really non-ideal and then your Queens
that's gonna be hit so with this with
this better Bishop on e5 should be okay
Ricki one Rick Ricky three Ricki three
king-king see - look G three and you're
making some sort of progress okay here
just we're gonna see everything try it
off and a draw is going to be agreed -
yup
the question is man is gonna agree to
draw or is it gonna is this going to
play out because he hasn't lead
he doesn't technically need to really
allow these games to finish prematurely
[Music]
no reason to really even play it out so
I wonder why they are no real time to
gain on the match clock or any other
settings but okay the player okay all
right so 15 to 9 with the bullet portion
one minute plus one second increment
left yep the players life
forsake their brakes my perspective here
yeah there's a three minute break
I think Wesley is making a competitive
and he could really see himself maybe
with an extra point maybe this would be
only a four game match a point swing I
mean those two blunderers he made his
good positions that would be a four four
point game
that he had converted those a deacon so
I think Wesley so his position here he's
still got chances he is out playing
Magnus in a few of these games but as
for Magnus he he is starting to fade a
bit or be a bit sloppy that's not yeah
he definitely was I think partly he
maybe got a little lacks when he jumped
out to eight nine game lead after the
five minute portion right and start
enjoying the Real Madrid game a little
too much but alright let's let's give a
shout out during this quick break
apologize to those of you who've been
paying close attention to the technical
difficulties something something
happened there with the show broadcast
thanks to Eric for our kind of carrying
it but we should be fixed now
masterclass you can now sign up you can
get Garry Kasparov's course
do it don't wait any longer go to
masterclass calm slash Ches we're gonna
check in real quick with another quick
word from them before we start the
one-minute portion and then we'll see if
Wesley cell can mount a further come
back he's gonna need it against magnus
carlsen in the final segment i'm trying
to come up with the comprehensive
picture that will be helpful for you to
become a better chess player and even a
better decision maker check I want to
show you the ultimate deflection the
ultimate sacrifice so here we are white
pawns see their advanced a7 b6 c6 the
ship is pinned all working white favor
but this one problem is check if white
King goes on a six then geometry works
in black they work we need to check and
it will be a perpetual white King will
not escape do you see any way to prevent
black Queen from attacking our King and
forcing draw has it work
Queen g5 and that's one of the lessons
of this endgame
I'm trying to come up with the
comprehensive picture that will be
helpful for you to become a better chess
player and even a better disease
all right and as we wait here for the
one-minute portion to start the players
have regathered themselves they are
sitting and we are ready to rock into
bullet without any further ado the final
segment of today's species championship
is gonna go down so let's do it
Eric your thoughts on what Leslie can do
to make sure the bullet works out for
him he can I think he can really make
this a close match do what he's been
doing and convert a little bit better
he's gonna have to play his absolute
best obviously but the consistency
showed and and he got better positions
as white in the three three two portion
I don't think he should change that
that's really like he had such a
disastrous five five minute portion I
think I think what he just did is
working and it's up to Magnus to to play
a bit better there if Wesley continues
it you know now you're right I mean I
guess it's be closer the Magnus
continues to remain very very relaxed
having a great time today but the the
bullet portion is under way we have a
half an hour left of games with the
fastest time control in the event and
you know you're right so we look at the
three-two portion there everyone can see
the scoreboard above the cameras Wesley
so finished up two games in the
three-minute portion which is even
greater than our prediction for that
segment for Wesley and I think part of
that was probably due Eric you would
agree to a little sloppiness by the
world champion clearly having a relaxed
time I guess you can relax a little bit
when you were up by eight almost nine
games and after a five-minute but but if
Wesley mounted an epic comeback he would
definitely regret the way he performed
in the three-minute shows yep yep No
Magnus is gonna have to play the bet
he's down 12 seconds here he's playing
a very suspicious line or position is
it's pretty bad
yeah he's asking for it that's where I
can sit here Queen f4 you're gonna try
to bring that other night on g3 day g4
and and put something on f6 in the
meantime though you are gonna generate
something here on the queenside but it
seems a little slow i if you can get 9f
one 93 94 96 that's game over any sort
of dark square penetration here is gonna
be light so the problem is I mean blacks
just playing sort of like anti
positional here I think madest knows it
too by though he's being very
provocative with his chest this is this
is something you don't see from many
other top players he gets away with it
sometimes I know he covers symptoms with
similar positions in bullet but I mean
this looks like like like I'm not sure
what's going on here yeah this is so
long it's almost mating for white I mean
it this is but I mean yeah the Wesley
must be very surprised that he's even in
this position yeah I mean you can take
everything and and everything in there
cousins I mean at this point it's just
me Magnus is is pushing the limits in
how bad his positions can be and he can
still play them like like can you win
like a terrible how bad does it have you
know oh my gosh he's winning Wesley so
it's just absolutely on tilt right now
it's not even not even oh my like that
is Erik gather yourself I was I don't
know what I just watched her Danny that
was why she's had to deal with Angus
Carlson was again that just the position
is resigned belen any form of of chess
is similar to the game that he was
already in a dead loss position and
swindled the 67th draw I mean again he's
giving us enough gift material to last
the social media lifetime with his
crack-ups on camera so I hope somebody
is is clipping the bleep out of this
homes in right now I mean you don't see
this Magnus over the board well we'll
see what kind of door yes we get in in
post interviews and post match interview
Zarek see that is that isn't it's really
good like me or some other temper people
uh I mean on camera I get yeah
where if the players were miked up you
know who knows what you'd hear that what
that is
look at that yeah Queen d5 rook e8
Bishop h6 there's Queen d6 there it's
not honey
it's not is Magnus I wonder what's in
the glass he's but but by the way he
resigned we you have Queen d6 right can
you at least buy Queenie six yeah it's
good the king upon anything is probably
losing but yeah you're right but why
immediately lost a hundred percent I
agree
well Wesley is clearly not has his best
chest today magnus carlsen has been on
fire despite a rather sloppy approach at
times but only 25 minutes remain before
I guess I guess it might be lost but I
thought you meant clay that okay okay
well anyways anyways Wesley here is
dealing with out of all the matches I've
seen in terms of just allowing like some
certain basic tactics that obvious like
you know he knows about and dealing with
with tilt Wesley I think has had it the
worst he's really gonna have to like I
mean I yeah it's very hard to recover
from some of these blunders but yeah
Magnus is Magnus is playable on another
planet right now right I mean after
dismantling Dingley Ren and and and
doing so and and just super so I want to
say pattern recognition Magnus has a
pawn on h4 Queen on e5 and a
dark-squared bishop
yep he's clearly gonna do something on
the dark squares he did this on the
other side he won that very nice game in
the 5-2 portion and yeah often goes for
things like this
Wesley defending his way good you're not
threatening Queen takes to you three
that's not even a move I want to do what
am i doing night h4 here
yeah a niche for a move what do you do
after night age for this doesn't look
healthy or any of these moves this is
like Bacchus it's like annoying airplane
it takes I'm almost tempted to play King
to f1 white doing his best to defend but
running out of useful moves nicely for
such a strong move now now this Queen is
being overloaded between the d2 bishop
like this is so active here even this in
booking boy this is you just you just
can't handle this now that night 62
could be played is night 62 and rook g5
I guess that's why the Wesley brought
the Bishop to c6 was to guard the threat
of mate on g2 he's gonna be six you've
seen this before
musics in Queen age - here comes Bishop
d6 the King runs but the rook is already
he's already won a game like this this
is this is like after Queen age one
night she won the bishop will come we've
already seen this before he won a game
exactly like this this is I mean I
called it like 20 moves ago that he was
gonna get his Queen and Bishop on that I
ignore h4 I mean it's it's staged elbow
for Western so super under the gun you
can see the difference in terms of how
this match has gone by the expressions
on each player's face frustrating for
Wesley so but but what can you do at
this point Magnus Carlsen is is putting
on a show
okay well the last few games we have
here in bullet are still worth something
and at this point in round 2 of the
speech has championship they're they're
worth almost hundreds of dollars do you
want to do some something I was worried
about is when I put [ __ ] I was worried
and aware that when I was on tilt and he
was killing me that he could fool fool
around and be me and he didn't and you
couldn't stop him like I would probably
lose if you played like King e2 or like
you'd like like there's a certain point
where yeah I was I thought it might be
publicly humiliated and it wasn't that
bad
terms like the openings or just like you
know sack a queen win with like rook
gods like how are you like one against
Lawrence Trent a few times things like
that like I was really concerned about
that they call it pulling at rent these
days when you uh you lose with regard so
so Wesley here dealing with well is yeah
this is uh this is quite an unpleasant
in-game the two bishops with no risk one
thing you might want to do is boxes put
the pot on be three so you can attack
that be two pond because otherwise you
have no targets and why it's gonna play
King f1 me to he's gonna take on edge to
here yeah he should which works yep
but even then this is good for white
outside past pawn to bishops to no risk
so so now this Bishop before rook takes
d5 slowly
he's blundering he's wandering away blah
blah when we're on pace to seeing if we
uh his farm for free match predictions
everybody currently given the way bullet
is going we are on pace to see an even
bigger win by magnus carlsen
despite wesley so sort of over
performing our algorithms metrics four
three two wesley so one that portion by
a score of sixty four but at this point
it's less than one percent chance the
wesley so could come back and win this
game he's almost mathematically
eliminated given the amount of time
that's left on the game clock it's one
of the things that's both fun and
sometimes disheartening right eric about
our about our format here that most
chess tournaments there isn't that that
aspect you have in regular sports where
you're playing against the clock right
if you're down by a goal you have to
score before the time runs out right and
it's something that in chess you have
that you have the time that applies to
each individual game but you don't
always have that overarching sort of
you're running out of time to make your
move and in this format that is one of
the exciting things but it means that
wesley unfortunately or maybe
fortunately given how his day is gone
his misery is almost over in twenty
minutes right depending on how you look
at it yeah depending on how you look at
it while on this game
Black has an attack for fries playing
quicker so it's funny in the 3/2 all of
a sudden Wesley sucks when quickly yes
confident wins wins the portion Magnus
here's to taking over control he's fine
quickly again and he looks like he's
having the time of his life
yeah I really do I don't have that much
fun anymore
Roger Pegasus is enjoying there like I
said and his and his but it just looks
happy like Norwegians or something I'm
either just sorry you don't know my gosh
its mate
he's got Queen g3 followed by Knight f3
coming in it's just gonna be over here
it comes it's overnight of three of
those nine takes up three by the way and
now it takes d4 and then yeah Bishop
takes d4 yeah yeah that's what I met I
mean he's gonna live it all it takes you
to there's worth takes you to that's
probably the immediate one yeah yeah
yeah Luke Wesley Wesley throws in the
towel there by the way we had to speak
to the tilt action and why we just know
that Wesley so is better than this
everybody I think Wesley just got off to
the wrong foot and has been beating
himself as as proof if you go through
any of the games here he lost several
completely winning positions up by plus
four or more and and even further Eric
somebody has now analyzed that game
where Wesley resigned and it actually
was a draw with no so it was my
impression yeah he resigned in a drawn
position despite a tricky sacrifice by
Magnus he just he just psychologically
is is so frustrated right now that he
didn't even realize that it was nothing
more than a draw so how many games in a
row or we out right now with Magnus here
it was 11 games it started out of six
games so yeah yep five is if I'm either
in a row yeah oh that's dangerous
territory right that's dangerous
territory there Magnus is up fifteen
seconds already that's just significant
considering the method started with one
minute now this is fine Wesley I might
also start like playing something uh
something funky something funky
seriously yeah might as well enjoy it
right have the last video sort of those
things when somebody plays age for first
move a lot of people reply
because they don't want to be the guy
that loses to age 4 they want to like
did their would they actually realize it
probably like rhymes and they do that so
I played h5 I am that guy who loses day
for seven plays h4 and I'm like I'm
gonna crush you e5 d5 go for the center
and I lose anyway you take on a 2 here
that is a good hunt well now you can't
yeah you could have but now you do this
event Akane - okay Brooke p7 check why
did you allow that okay takes pawn it's
gonna be two pawns out too many pawns
not enough time for Wesley so you play a
four hear you play g3 afterwards and
black plays h5 is quite quick okay it's
going for this he's trying to trapping
h2 will trap the bishop which is good
he's gonna go g3 yeah h5
Bishop yeah well this is this this could
be a halt because a 2 and C 2 are not
the best pawns right but with all the
other problems on the King side I'm
inclined to think that oh I'm actually I
can't I can't say two pawns is not
convincing because the base is probably
a draw for blacken if you have the split
pause the other times you can hold with
the obstacle Bishop Hiram's yeah yeah
but why is the H Vaughn to be a passed
pawn so King g6 Bishop h6 and now he's
gonna put his legs on Nautilus is
winning this is winning this is gonna
turn into six wrong I should be stuck on
aged six and he's gonna either gonna
forces or this is this is yeah nasty
nasty nasty
yeah he's got it so he's got the two
pawns you don't even need that Bishop
you don't even need that anyhow Magnus
realized it was winning long before the
computer did yes the evaluation bar only
now starting to shift and realize that
yeah white is winning and Wesley also
knows it just simply throws in the towel
he knows he's in zoogs wrong and we've
got a lot of time left don't we I mean
this the scores getting run up right now
yep
twenty-one to nine is the current score
Magnus Carlsen on pace to win the match
by hey we're already up to thirty games
you guys predicted it looks like they're
gonna eclipse that yeah we're already
the thirty games we predicted
rematch they're on pace to set a record
as far as total match games the record
was 31 set by Jeffrey Zhang and Maxine
Bosch Telegraaf but that's gonna be
shattered here well
Wesley here is so h6 played he's not
getting good positions he this is he's
unrecognizable right now he's not
getting any any I can bullet I'm quite
concerned I'm quite concerned right now
he's really he's really getting worst
positions with white with black and well
I mean it's just I don't know what is
almost a matter of formalities right he
doesn't want to throw in the towel in
the match because you know one you owe
it to the fans and you owe it to the
format you do your best to continue to
fight on but I would I would be with you
and they say that Wesley should mix it
up and just play some some mess around
stuff at this point and kind of enjoy
the last 10 minutes yeah easier said
than done
yes yes yeah so I was looking at this
this this is could be a mating net for
black if you're not careful he's trying
to win they have to pawn and keep the
Queens on the board yeah so Queen f3 I
mean this game should should not lesser
losses Wesley's be worried about him
sort of mating net over here yeah but
Wes is actually uh much I wouldn't see
much better here yeah I would see much
better cleaning most traps at the ships
and ideal setup here
that's a very interesting move that he's
gone for he's starting Bishop e1 he's if
he can fix the Queen set pawns he's
arguing that he should be aware oh yeah
okay Wesley's gonna get an established
well she's gonna be able to push this
he's not Wesley is not losing this game
I will make that prediction now for sure
that's a very safe stop the bleeding
officially in this game you heard the
prediction from Eric Hanson that's
actually important because you don't
want to lose 10 games in a row you know
there's a term for that but
yeah yeah we don't want yeah we don't
want them for everybody's sake including
the kids at home so he wants the King
walk he puts the bishop on HIV once
provoked f6 f6 lose immediately to King
e6 but now he's gonna king walk to a 6 C
5b v e6 if black plays f6 which he might
have to right now now you put the king
back and try to get the King back to f5
and go for the h6 spawn so he is
maximizing this position now you're
starting to see sadness to show he's
dying right now
if king f7 who loses the king b6 so
Magnus is under serious pressure right
now in fact see 7 is the only move I see
and now I might be tempted to play King
fe4 at the right moment yeah and try to
run in still think it's a still think
it's a draw with best play but he's uh
okay he's gonna hold us e6 pawn with
Bishop e5 if the black king comes to d6
but now he can maybe play now maybe he's
got his got his king in the right right
place now this is a draw
yes is just that this is just a draw you
can't avoid trading off the pawns on the
Kings side or allowing the bishops again
outpost on g5 so well anyways he you
stop the bleeding there but there's
still a bit of time and he's missing
that ball when it's just Magnus Magnus
is a really good ball player people
always think of his blitz but I'm below
the only guy he's lost to it was was was
not I'm sure they played other times as
well as I'm clear yep how good he really
is online he's just all we know is he's
he's super good and yep his healing is
has to be established let establish yet
but yeah 3,000 3100 a bullet is
something he may reach at the end of
this match if he continued although he's
gonna lose a few points after drawing
this one so for those of you before we
lose any viewers obviously at this point
we know Magnus Carlsen will be going on
to win this match mathematically not
really possible for Wesley to catch him
however we have interviews coming up
with the players as soon as the next
eleven and a half minutes are over and
if you're wondering when the next speech
has champion
ship match is mark your calendars it's
only in three days magnus carlsen will
be moving on to take on sasha Grichuk
right there you see the number one seed
will take on the number five seed that
match has already been confirmed by both
magnus carlsen and sasha creek as a
possible date it is it is it's going
down in three days everybody wow that
was awesome
Sasha Creek now that's a match that
Magnus I'm gonna say will not be able to
get away with it with so much laughter
in the in the in the middle of the match
because I I think Grichuk is is is a
force to be reckoned with against Magnus
in this format yeah I mean okay Magnus
is bowl favorite but we yeah I feel good
bad talking about that while Wesley's
still yours you know about fighting he's
going for that for that bull win but yes
we shook might be in this toughest
possible challenger i think i yeah
that's that's how i think it although i
have to say my world my prediction was
completely off every Fabiano beating we
shook and blitz recently in st. louis it
seems like there are more and more like
dangerous blitz players and it's getting
harder to predict but the one thing is
Magnus to me by a he best at all formats
when he put it together he I think he's
better is the difference between him and
speech s and others may even eclipse
classical because yes very hard for
people to keep keep pace with him you
know time was intuition his judgment all
that is like the best in my opinion its
luck we've already drawn in the results
the results would back you up so I agree
and he's uh he's here he's gonna swing
his Queen over at age four and have some
fun at the right time maybe was gonna
have to play queen g4 or something but
he's just got an attack here and black
is a very clumsy setup
yeah he's calculating here maybe there's
other things to think about in regards
to how to get control over the e-file
moves there you go he does eventually go
he actually played Quidditch for yeah
Ricky why now just rookie one right yeah
I thought maybe rookie one first but
this is also he's going for this he's
starting birthday c6 check yeah
so why she's going for a jog here but
it's not going well Queen of fate
rooks gonna go over to d1 rook do you
won yeah Ricky to do one Ricky do yes
he's not even nice c6 everyone because
the a a rook just Falls and mating net
is on Wesley so Queen time no he
resigned with almost no time there maybe
yeah it's okay well it's a 22 and a half
9f Pete as I said I mean the match is
over mathematically at this point so I
don't necessarily feel bad talking about
that matchup with Rick but of course we
have to talk to Wesley about some of
those critical moments in the 3-2
portion where he really felt like he was
gaining momentum but the truth is
overall as it's not really something you
can judge because Magnus Carlsen was
just the best chess player on the planet
today that's who he is and in case you
didn't get the memo and and he and he he
won the match so so that's it everybody
that's what we saw and we still have a
few more games of it than we maybe will
get some some nice some my sexy check
lights here before it's all done look at
this
well keeps getting pressured in
substitute he's getting like a lot of
mating attacks he is 94 is on the table
I would maybe even you know when you
think about how stressful classical
chesses and the pressure he has lets his
retain that title
I think blitz chess is a very nice
format like Magnus try to enjoy Queen g3
and Bishop takes us to the first it's
also possible they should take Syria you
win win the rook and Wesley may resign
out of discussed you know Wesley it
needs to just enjoy it a little bit
right now it takes three I don't even
give up how to even give up yeah
Bishop takes after Nancy 1787 it's gonna
be an end game where black is up to
pawns
plus he's got white in a box
it really looks like he's put wisely so
in a box this match it's my king in a
box a king in a box
you ever heard 21 Queen e1 mate no I
haven't okay good but but this is this
is Wesley laughing a little bit now all
right well Wesley soz chameleons in a
box
magnus carlsen is out of control but
this show has been off the chain Eric
this has had a blast honestly it has
been I mean it's nice that Wesley he won
the 3-2 portion yeah it really so like
on the edge of our seat did and it
wasn't all all bad here it's very hard
to maintain composure in Bullitt and he
just had a had a slow start
we saw what's going on with magnets now
he just won't stops
he won't stop can't stop he's cracking
up I'm laughing just when you see
somebody laughing sometimes you laugh
you know I have that problem Chester
Vince if someone's off thinking about
the board playing I was the lava thought
cast you know a broadcast I can't help
it so it's yeah well too bad tough day
for one that's a moralizing Danny for
tomorrow yes yeah I mean I guess the
thing is the players don't see the other
players that they know they'd say if
they do an effort to see you know to
have the webcams up they could it's not
like it's hidden but I most of them
don't go out of their way to do that I
think the one who might by the way is
Hikaru
sometimes I call his certain looks to
the camera that makes me think he's
looking at Roy he's watching his
opponents reaction do you ever think
when they're laughing you made a good
joke and the players love you ever like
pirate or something did you ever like
think has to do with you listening yeah
nagisa's told me several times how much
he waits to just mute me when he's
playing so feels bad feels bad news ya
know but he's uh yeah he can hold his
own in terms of trash talking Magnus but
sometimes I mean maybe I've had that dog
with you Caro where sometimes he lets it
slip that he might be
Kokoro I think sometimes has has tuned
into the broadcast this is a funny
position where blocks down upon but his
king of saw acted I think positions so
okay it's so hard to push those those
three kings at pawns for for Wyatt but
ya know it's uh ooh
again a lot of peace because of Brooke
g3 King takes another three so what he's
gonna do is he's gonna win an exchange
every King takes h4 rook GA yeah yeah
okay he went for the peace out I think I
think these yeah this is oh man oh man
this is oh man the bleeding feels bad
man I want to thank everybody who tuned
in today all the new subscribers all the
support of chess we're gonna yeah new
viewers this is blast again the next
speech is championship match will also
feature we might as well dubbed this
Magnus week on chess calm November 21st
he will take on Sasha Krish again right
now
the Train is off the tracks for Wesley
so at this point it's a crashed like way
back at Grand Central Station it's over
just a matter of time then and Magnus
Carlsen is back over 3100 bullet
seeing this makes me wish I'd like to
see magnets play more bullet online I
went just like I would cancel a date to
watch magnets play bullet I would I mean
you know funny funny thing I don't know
if you saw the tweet I put out when you
were playing magnets in that little man
or if you saw that but I was in the
middle of I was actually just got done
coaching Nash's my oldest son's
basketball game there's no new soccer
game and all of us were there and I was
telling the kids and my wife I'm like
hey guys Eric's playing magnets like
Magnus is playing and they don't even
know but we all stopped and watch you
guys play several games in a row it was
pretty funny when I'm always happy to
features in the Magana table family
gather and yet actually unifying like
the one people like to watch like well
Shana remembers you have you know that's
that's true since I went Tara back when
we were young young young uns Wesley the
problem here is yes he lost his night
his position even I know it almost
started you like Wesley was gonna get a
win and the opposite happened there as
blacks somehow wins the knife for freed
Magnus once again smiling and kind of
Wesley trying to figure out the right
way to keep the attack going maybe I'm
we're problem for you okay three well
you have to stop c6 before that would
cover it so here at Queen takes e5 yeah
Brooke d3 we're not getting any other
squares and Queen c6 is a fantastic move
totally shuts out the diagonal and put
your King back to b7 you're gonna put
your Bishop to c5 okay Wesley stop that
very good idea but I don't envision MIT
he may have blundered this by the way
rook b3 king CA heaven or king c7 that's
better okay no there's nothing no follow
up
nada yeah he wants to play Queen a5 you
play d6 but you can do rook e8 and then
Ricky Jenny resigns what is this 10 10
and a half to half and there is this is
the last game officially in bullet
before chess960
we will let the players know with only a
minute left in the game clock I guess
I'm assuming the game doesn't end in the
next 25 seconds but
this is a very impressive full
performance by the way from it from a
guy who seems very relaxed like just he
hasn't been making blunders like he's
having fun fun he's maybe I'd suspicious
positions like he but it's like he's
doing that on purpose but he's not
making any like big mistakes he's very
consistent very consistent flow right
now yeah well tough day for Wesley will
we'll have the interviews here quickly
everybody don't go anywhere we'll see
how the players feel about the match
maybe you'll catch a Magnus gem or two
and those post match interview so don't
go anywhere
Wesley not not a sweeter kinder honestly
more humble person in the top top in the
world right I mean so it's tough to see
him lose like this obviously magnus
carlsen is is a beast that's know well
that's the PG definition but Wesley
Wesley a super nice and classy guy so I
expect I expect nothing and nothing but
that from him in the interviews but a
tough day for Wesley right hard to watch
it happen when you just have so much
respect and Wesley is just such a
monster himself and then you just get
out class and then you find yourself on
tilt because you beaten yourself in
several games that you had no business
losing and then you know Bob's your
uncle right he has a good position here
he will I have a feeling he's gonna win
this game
rookie seven Rick EDA a seven you just
gained upon the a pond
I think Wesley is on his way to winning
his first game in the bowl portion so
any consolation prize when Augustus
would be would be taking Magnus Carlsen
back below 3,100 before the day's throw
there's the pong his time is okay the
night's gonna go to d3 and c5 this is
still annoying to convert but block is
obviously better that extra pawn so
let's see if Wesley can convert this and
stop the bleeding
now it's gonna c5 on a good day maybe
Quinn anyone to stop arcade stop trades
because you Locke wants the trade ease
up upon so so Rick okay seven Queen is
six makes you something there okay
that's a good move blocks everything out
ooh I didn't see that one oh man oh man
like like how do you
how do you find these like a crazy shot
maintaining right but it's just a nuts
position now oh it's totally turn the
tables Danny yeah this is actually good
for why that's that is that's that's
unreal that scratching his head what a
flip what a flip Wesley drop the drop
yes okay rook it is lost
yeah what a turnaround that was that was
just incredible you jinxed it I'm
kidding not your fault but you said he
was gonna win
I said he was on his way to win it
that's right sorry I do not your guests
converted it's not your fault that is no
that's that's really but he's so he
still is output here is just incredible
a strange approach by Magnus there gets
stronger but he gets stronger not many
you guys really get stronger and he's
like final segments yeah chess and he's
definitely the best finisher I think
there's ever been in terms of how he
plays in the final hours well we will
have the players joining us in just a
moment we have one bullet chess960 game
which is always a hoot I think a hoot
and a holler as the as a term the kid
the cool kids use these days I'm a
grandma hoot and a holler you mean
that's not still a relevant phrase
that's a that's a Canadian grandma's
saying no all right well Wesley Wesley
might get himself a hoot and a holler
perpetual if he's lucky no I don't see
it I don't even see a check besides the
Queen trade here yeah I was gonna say
even Bishop g6 and then rush the D pawn
and he's gonna bring the King in he's
gonna box out Wesley's okay she's gonna
put the pawn on but he can just push in
the night that like all denied barely
stops at okay yeah yeah well the night
stops it except he's gonna win the night
he's gonna still a chance for
steelmaking there's always a chance for
Stillman that's true okay p7 check okay
there we go
oh it's on it's the wrong color do we
have any zoogs 155 in Magnus does the
head ma this is this is this is
the way he's dancing instead up for the
game just it's true but look at look at
how quickly he convinces he's bought
these things like the whole sequence
like he had time he could have waited do
I push the deeper on his his is his
impulses I mean just for the I'd love
yeah just for the record this position
is not a force mate in nineteen
everybody we currently are having some
issues with our evaluation of the
chess960 positions so that was the final
computer assessment after Magnus played
the brilliant Bishop d5 and then did a
little head Bob again please help us
clip some moments in the chat these have
been some really fun moments let's get
us out there social media tag tag at
chest bra TV on Twitter you can also tag
Hansen chest you see him and if you're
not know if you have it if you somehow
if this is your first ever chess
experience that we brought you into the
speech just go to go over to twitch TV
slash chest bra and follow and subscribe
those guys too that's what Eric does on
a regular basis I'm serious we gotta
know I'm going to be playing a bullet
blitz match probably in C asura this
next week
oh yeah should be fun stuff yeah mutual
trash talk well yeah sir beyond chaos
yeah I love it in person for those of
you don't know yes also can hold his own
despite that sweet smooth and silky
voice or yes can hold it up with a
little trash talk I've never felt more
obliterated than actually playing
bughouse with him and Aronian when they
just destroyed me look I mean like
lavon's I guess you're the one who
toured me on the board and emotionally
morally mentally like seriously I went
home and like thought about things like
wow it was it feels bad man playing
against Aronian and bughouse yeah no I
those guys trash talk very well and I've
been on losing and with you I've gone
down with you - yeah yeah you you you
you get to form that friendship there's
nothing like that foreign ship of being
abused by Levon Aronian in bughouse
alright well Wesley may be on his way to
doing one final abusive act of his own
maybe he'll get a win here he is
currently about to win a night I think
he's winning a night he's got a better
pong structure he's not getting
this game Magnus has only in I don't
have four that can cause any problems
no no swindles no swindles because he's
got an ex yeah he's all copper comes
Queen c7
well don't Queen c7 butters of the game
with Queen takes nine that would be that
would be what I'm talking about right um
the only way to lose did he really
King age 7 Knight takes e4 Queen e1
check its mate he blundered wonder that
Wesley blundered that this is incredible
that was a position I don't think he
could ever blender he just was nowhere
he could still win here with Queen d7 or
Queen c7 it's still tricky yes the quick
can also swing to f4 at some point come
on Wesley come on Wesley yes his winning
the Knights he's got 25 Oh
he's trading Queens Oh Wesley he was
soul winning this game he would never
ever lose this to tilt it's like three
hours I'm just this is psychology of the
game of the moment those triple the
difficult aspect of playing against
Magnus Carlsen and we'll we'll bring the
players on now as we unmuted Wesley so
Wesley is here trying to unmute Magnus
for some reason having a little bit of
trouble there we go well joining us now
of course are the players that have just
finished entertaining us for the last
three and a half hours Magnus you're not
gonna tell us you didn't play your best
chest today too right although we could
not you looking over your shoulder were
you watching Real Madrid that was our
suspicion yeah I was pushing I was
pushing that game a bit okay and what
was the final result I haven't we
haven't checked yet I don't know it was
nearly at halftime and then after that I
didn't it was noon the last time I saw
in the second half
well you seem to have a very good time
today
you-you-you came out with the
performance in the five-minute portion
that honestly haven't ever seen anything
like it you jumped out to an eight game
lead what was working for you today as
you as you had a lot of fun it seemed
now I think he was not as best in the
five minutes he was plundering quite a
bit and he didn't seem very comfortable
like even positions in which I was
clearly worse I felt like I could get
back in the game and then frankly
speaking in a three minute portion I was
out playing most of the time and I was
fortunate that I didn't lose more of my
lead and so when I kind of looked myself
into that six game lead then I felt very
comfortable going for the bullet and at
that time I knew that I could just have
fun well you are you found you found
your way to saving some tough positions
hey Wesley are you there Wesley can you
hear us yeah Wesley do you mind lowering
your webcam for us just so we can see a
little more of your of your face the fan
the fans want to see your smile not sure
if you can hear us Wesley I don't think
you can okay well Magnus you swindled
this rook g1 rook takes g7 at that point
saving a game like that it seemed like
you you were willing to play out a lot
of positions and hold honor are you um
I don't even know what the question is I
don't have a question for it because it
was very entertaining and impressive to
see you hold on and so many tricky and
weird and bad positions but did you go
go ahead no like I there were many times
especially in the bullet that I
considered resigning and then I thought
okay what the hell let's give it a go in
yeah this rook g1 roof g7 was egregious
of course I didn't deserve that at all
Wesley can you hear us now yeah sorry oh
no no worries
let me doing I can hear enough first of
all thank you thank you for the for the
match today I know we know it didn't
work
in the way that you probably hoped or
intended and but it seemed that when you
when you lost your way a little bit the
five-minute portion that that maybe some
of your confidence went with it you
struggle to convert on some clearly
winning positions that you just you find
yourself just frustrated and beating
yourself up after some of the games
today
it's kind of disappointing to have bad
starts and then stir the five made it's
kind of hard to to catch up I should
have played the her I should have played
better to have chances in this match but
well you know get get there one day with
some practice tough match you can't let
him in the three-minute portion yeah and
and you want you know you want a few
games in a row and and we were you know
we were we were we were looking for a
match heading into the bullet is it is
it is it just how do you recover from a
game like that when when he Magnus finds
this rook takes g7 right does that just
kind of let the air out of your sails
and tough to tough to bounce back yeah
it's tough to bounce back and I mean I
thought you know just play my game and
just play fast minute and defend was
brilliant hey but I probably had some
several winning chances in that in that
game but anyway he's a fan no matter the
score in the three minutes because once
the bullet the one minute game comes
impossible for me to play you spent a
lot of time this week playing on chess
calm you were you were clearly trying to
prep in and and and get your get your
online chess bullet and blitz game up
for this match then you didn't you had a
very as you stuck to a consistent
opening repertoire at least in the
five-minute portion was that something
you prepared trying to get those sort of
ready collie kind of positions you were
getting as white yeah well I have some
ideas on the under setups you know
basically I just want to play fast and
very logical in the openings and I think
to me percent make sense to play the
main lines because
Magnus knows them very well anyway
and it's just the player who has who
knows the opening better like has a big
advantage in in bits I think it doesn't
make sense for me to go to main line so
I just play and beat to your article
and he totally made made sense to me got
it bad
yeah it workout and I spent some time
playing in Chester Tom this week in the
last but most of my games were created
without increment I I think most players
without increment on chess calm and in
the five do it so kind of a different
game because it's really like seven
minutes each
well I'll say Wesley you you gave us one
of the most thrilling matches to date so
far in our format and in your in your a
victory over uh nice carry and even
though we're obviously sorry for you
that it didn't work out today we want to
thank you for for answering our
questions and for being it's still very
entertaining you guys both but gave us
some awesome chess moments Magnus before
we let you go the fans know that you're
taking on Sasha grishnack on November
21st that's only in three days from now
how do you feel you stack up against a
former world boots champion there well I
think the three-minute portion is really
where there's a lot of room for
improvement so if I can do that well
there also then I think I have a very
good chance so I'm very much looking
forward to that and also following the
other match between recurrence again
well Eric any other questions or should
we let our let our champions go and then
we'll see we'll see Magnus in a few days
in which what which Wesley best luck
best of luck yeah probably they're
they're pretty tired I would like to
take a little bit of credit thanks
Magnus for the match I never said that
before but those I hope I helped form
you up sorry for for leaving but I
to go at that point you get you guys not
you guys stop my family day in its
tracks when you guys started playing
that match Magnus it was pretty fun so
but we really appreciate you guys thank
you thank you both for everything Magnus
we'll see you in a few days and Wesley
have a good evening
Thank You Danny thank you Eric thanks
thank you see you soon through this
well Eric we we will let our let our
players go and you and I will talk real
quickly about the match we're gonna have
in just a couple days Magnus Carlsen
taking on Sasha Kirk there is no
official date yet for Nakamura versus
Kuryakin that is because if those who
don't follow the professional chess
world you wouldn't know that hey kar
Nakamura is in Majorca right now and the
fede Grand Prix circuit rockin is in a
tournament in Romania both players are
headed to London it's pretty difficult
right now working with a super super
busy global chess schedule but what do
you think will happen now that Wesley is
officially out with Magnus and Grichuk I
think Magnus crucial I think both both
the semi-final matches I mean I think
Richard can beat
Magnus in blitz he's done it before they
were very competitive but I'm concerned
about the bullet portion like Magnus is
really shown like how quickly he can he
can run up the score he's against Grisha
plastered it against Wesley now and he
seems to like he's able to take every
time control and start fresh right like
resin and and and so I think that's
still what's gonna come down to it's
gonna be similar similar to last year
but we shook is going to have to convert
a little bit better in blitz and
significantly improve his bullet but I
do expect it to be if super competitive
matchup and for the other one I think
it's also toss-up and people are going
to be more and more surprised by
kuryakin's speed chess skills yeah I
tend to agree and I already kind of
previewed an MP and sort of foreshadowed
that we've got some fun a statistical
preview information coming out based on
how we've measured all of our players
and their their performances their
accuracy and all these different
portions and we love those chest the
chest stats and chest data so it may not
be the favorite you think between
horn honking morning sir Kuryakin but I
can say that I bet we're all gonna be in
for a super exciting match and probably
you and I will have the call for that
for that battle there so all right
everybody there you go you have it in
front of you Magnus Carlsen we'll be
back online in three days for tuning in
thanks for all the support go to go to
twitch TV slash chess bra and show the
chess bras some love and Eric we'll see
you see you in a little while for the
next beat boom thanks everyone for
tuning in had a blast keep getting those
numbers up we're pushing chess on Twitch
take care guys